And we're live.
All right,
Paul,
first of all,
welcome.
Thank you for coming here.
And you are probably one of the most
requested people from the Internet that
I've ever had.
So feel good about that.
And I'm honored.
And he the first guy ever to wear a
mushroom hat.
Okay.
That's really a hat made out of
mushrooms.
It's made from this on the do mushroom.
Um,
it's called families from materials.
It grows on birch trees throughout the
world.
But this is an example of why I think
shamanistic Lee plants mushrooms become
significant.
There's a plurality of benefits.
So this mushrooms a fire starter
mushroom.
It allowed for the portability of fire.
There's no doubt that we came from
Africa.
We migrated north,
we discovered something new called
winter.
Oops.
This allowed for the portability of
fire.
You can hollow this mushroom output
embers of a fire inside and carry fire
for days.
If your clan could not rekindle fire in
Europe in the wintertime,
you would die.
So when you.
This has actually made by some ladies in
Transylvania.
Can I feel that?
Yeah.
And it's a hard wood.
Conk.
Oh Wow.
But when you soak it in lye water,
ashes and water it,
the laminate's into this fabric.
Oh,
let me feel that.
It's very soft.
It's also called German felt.
Wow.
It's extremely flammable.
So it revolutionized warfare because Don
Nepal,
iconic napoleonic times,
this is the punk that ignited gunpowder.
So even the Chinese invented the Chinese
invented gunpowder,
the Europeans and then had the rifle.
So this allowed flint spark guns to
ignite the gunpowder.
This feels amazing.
It is as big a piece.
Can you get that?
That's a great question.
Depending on the size of the conch on
beech trees,
they're much bigger than birch.
These trees just naturally get larger.
So the larger,
the more fabric you can tear.
But this mushroom is made of mycelium
and basically what that fabric is a
cellular fabric called mycelium.
And this is,
I have,
actually,
I have one that caught on fire because
someone was smoking a joint near me.
And uh,
the and the embers of the joint got on
my hat to just immediately go up.
No,
it burns really slowly.
So it's a fuse.
It's fantastic for delayed explosions as
because you can light this thing and
beekeepers for hundreds of years used
this for smoking the hives of bees
because it's um,
it's just,
we could,
we could light it now.
I mean the whole thing would,
one flick of the bic and this thing will
smoke entirely in about 10 minutes and
turn nothing.
Nothing into white ash.
Wow.
Your fire alarms may go off though.
Yeah,
probably.
Yeah.
Also with this thing,
this larger piece,
they would hollow this out,
put an ember in there.
Would they have.
They'll have to blow on the ember as
they hiked.
Well,
you could blow it on a little bit and
you cap it and then you can put it in
your pocket.
The famous iceman that was found on the
border of view in Austria,
he had this tethered to his right side,
which is a position of significance.
You know,
things that you need,
like your knife,
you know,
and things you want to make sure you
have if you're right handed you this on
the right side.
So there's this one example.
We have a thread of knowledge of use of
mushrooms that goes over millennia and
most of those threads have been frayed
or broken in the chain of knowledge,
but this is one of the threads that was
not broken and it's significant.
I think it's we are much more dependent
upon mushrooms when we were forest
people than we are now seemingly in the
cities,
but it's coming full circle very
quickly.
Well,
mushrooms are weird in that some of them
are incredibly edible and nutritious and
other ones will kill you and sometimes
they look really similar to each other.
Well,
this is the mystery of mushrooms and I
think it speaks to also Michael Phobia,
the fear of mushrooms.
R Gordon Wasson first coined that term,
but when you think about it in your
visual landscape with animals,
you see them for months,
years in plants,
so you have a familiarity factor,
but mushrooms that come up and
disappeared for five days.
Some of them can feed you,
some can kill you,
some can heal you,
some can send to you on a spiritual
journey.
So to have something so powerful and yet
so ephemeral,
it's natural for humans to avoid that
which they don't understand out of fear
because they don't know the difference.
But you know,
23 primates consume mushrooms,
humans being one of them,
and so that speaks to a long ancestral
use of mushrooms going back in our
primate evolutionary tree for a very,
very long time.
What,
how many species of mushrooms are there?
You know that you asked,
you asked me that question five years
ago,
I would've said one point $5 million and
now we're up to about $5.
Million is being is being estimated.
Plant fungi outnumber plants five to 10
to one,
and I just speak at Ted and I've gone to
these ted conferences,
but it's shocking with the smartest
brains in the world.
Not until just recently did they realize
what us mycologists have known for a
long time.
Thirty percent of the soil mass when
you're walking on soil,
the 30 percent of the biological carbon
is fungal.
And the biggest,
biggest whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Say that again.
Thirty percent.
Thirty percent of soil is fungal mass
living and dead of healthy soil,
so and this is the biggest repository of
carbon in the world in the ground is
related to these fungal networks.
So there is about eight point three to
about 10 million species on the planet
about right now,
about half of those are fungal species.
They outnumber plants up to eight to
1:10
to one by by some estimates,
a really nice,
interesting metric in one meter of a
tree root for every meter of a tree
root.
There's a kilometer of Mycelium,
I think of that three feet versus 2100
feet so that the extensiveness of the
mycelial network in our landscapes is
vast and it's.
It's a,
as I call it,
Earth's natural internet as it is.
These are membranes that are literally
sensitive.
I think they're sentient.
They respond to every footprint that we
take on this planet.
And as you walk across landscapes,
you're breaking wood and that makes new
nutrition available.
So the competition of fungi to find that
new new nutritionist,
fierce.
And so first to the menu winds.
So this is something that we are now
understanding how essential they are for
preserving biodiversity and for the
health of the ecosystems as well as our
own personal health.
So when you say you think they're
sentient,
to what degree?
I mean and you're not talking about just
like silicide and your Mascara.
We're kind of intellectually provincial
in that we are using language and we've
ended terms in order to describe
concepts that we're trying to.
We're struggling with.
So the.
Let me describe it this way,
that we separated from fungi $650
million years ago.
Maybe you did.
Dude.
I know some people that are probably
still will.
Basically we,
we,
we are descendants of fungi.
We share a more common ancestry with
fungi than we do with any of their
kingdom and fungi are closer to animals
and the plants.
Animals came from fungi.
You and I are actually fungal bodies.
I'm speaking to basically another fungal
body right now.
So Joe Rogan,
I mean whether you know it or not,
you are basically a fungal mass from a
cellular point of view under the
microscope.
A human cells,
animal cells.
And Fungal cells are very,
very similar.
We exhale carbon dioxide,
inhale oxygen,
as do fungus.
The fungus does.
We separated from fungi.
Basically,
we chose the route to encapsulate our
nutrients in a cellular Osaka stomach,
digesting our nutrients within the
fungal systems,
digest their nutrients externally.
They exhale oxygen,
inhale carbon dioxide and their network
like design allows them to respond to
catastrophic.
And what I mean by that is that the
mycelial networks,
they're so dense in the soil and they
have literally hundreds of billions of
tips.
And as these tips are growing out,
they tend to be polynucleotide at the
tips and it allows them to upregulate
new enzymes,
acid sequences,
et cetera.
So if there's a new ecological
challenge,
new food source,
a new toxin or something,
these fungal networks are so a great
plasticity in being able to code for new
sequences from their DNA.
So all you need is one of those hundreds
of billions of tips to find a new enzyme
to break down a toxin or a new food
source.
And what happens then is that
information then is incorporated
genetically into the mycelial network
and the mycelium then surges because as
new food logically and so when it surges
named creates a new what's called a
sector of Mycelium,
we now know there's evidence that the
mycelial network then that benefits from
that tip exploration and discovery.
So these are like massively resilient,
adaptive organisms that have a network
based design,
not dissimilar from that of our neural
networks,
not dissimilar from the computer
internet and more and more that I
explore this,
the more I'm convinced that we will find
network based organisms throughout the
cosmos,
probably fungal systems and fungal
systems ultimately give rise,
in our case animals and it's more likely
we'll find fungal animal relationships
all throughout the universe.
Do you think
that there's some unknown way that
animals are connected in some sort of a
similar way as well,
that if,
if animals came from fungus and fungus
has this incredible way of communicating
with each other,
do you think that there's something like
that with the animal kingdom that we
haven't discovered?
Well,
that stimulates my thought into talking
about the microbiome,
the mycelial landscapes,
networks,
they don't live by themselves.
They select a microbiome of bacteria and
other organisms that rest upon the
mantle.
These fungal networks are the foundation
of the food web.
Well,
similarly,
we have a microbiome and it's really
interesting that the many of the
bacterial diseases that infect fungi
also affect us.
Our best antibiotics against bacteria
come from fungi.
Penicillin being the obvious example,
but we have found out during sex next
gen sequencing,
and this has never been published
before,
that the mycelial mats growing in the
very same wood chips in our case that
we'd been fermented.
We had a thousand fold difference in the
relative abundance of Genera of bacteria
from the very same wood chips.
Two different mushroom species planted
on these wood chips and the microbiomes
that were created and selected for by
the mycelium were vastly different.
This really strongly supports the
concept is the hypothesis with quickly
becoming a theory.
I'll explain the difference in a minute,
but this really supports the concept
that I've long believed that a spouse,
that these mycelial networks are there,
not just happenstance,
they are just creating the habitats and
the flora and then ultimately the fauna
that are resident within the ecosystem
to guarantee the plurality and the
biodiversity of the ecosystem by
creating the plants that create,
that grow up,
that feed the animals,
the insects to create the debris fields
and then feed the mycelium for the
benefit of the progeny of the mushrooms
out form thereafter.
So these are deterministic organisms
that are setting the stage for
ecological evolution.
And you think that they're doing this in
a conscious manner.
Well,
see again,
we're victims of our consciousness
trying to define what is conscious and
what a smart and one of the best
arguments I've had,
my brother builds a super genius,
is far smarter than myself and he was
editing one of my books,
mycelium running how mushrooms can help
save the world.
And and he goes,
Paul,
you cannot say that mycelium is
intelligent and that you can't say
nature is intelligent.
I go,
wait,
Bill,
I respect you,
but you didn't realize that how poc of
the statement that you're giving me,
you're telling me nature is not
intelligent and yet you are born of
nature.
Using the mind to conceive the concept
that challenge the idea that nature is
not intelligent when you are part of
nature.
I rest my case.
Yeah,
that's,
that's indefensible.
So yeah,
so we're.
We create language and words to describe
concepts.
So you feel like your brother was sort
of hampered by these predetermined
categories that we like to put things
into it.
You have a word,
use that word.
The word is very clearly defined in our.
Thank you.
Yes.
Language is code and we don't have.
We haven't elaborated the code yet to
elucidate the concepts that we're trying
to articulate.
That does not mean that just because you
can't prove it's true doesn't mean it
hasn't happened.
So as our vocabulary increases,
you know,
as our lexicon of language increases of
more robust than I think we can better,
better describe,
test and prove that these concepts are
true,
but we are biologically provincial.
When we think about how limited we are,
we're truly neanderthals with nuclear
weapons.
I mean this is when you look at the how,
how important natural ecosystems are,
try to replicate them.
They're very,
very difficult to replicate due to their
complexity,
so I think the more that we study
nature,
most all of us scientists subscribe to
the adage that the more we studied the
subject,
the more we realized we didn't know and
the Hubris of us thinking that these
things cannot occur,
did not occur,
will not occur,
really speaks to our provincial attitude
towards nature.
The idea that these fungus fungi are
creating their environment and almost
they're the architects of this
environment.
They're establishing the landscape for
all these different creatures and
lifeforms to live is unbelievably
fascinating.
The idea that and also that they're
connected,
right?
They're connected in some sort of almost
like a neural network and there's,
what is that thing in the Pacific
northwest,
the one fungus group that's essentially
the largest living organism on the face
of the earth.
Yeah.
The largest organism in the world so far
discovered is a mycelial mat.
Twenty 200 acres in size and that's
equivalent to about 665 football fields.
That's one animal is one man,
one mycelial mat.
It's a honey mushroom that kills trees.
It's an edible mushroom,
but think of this.
Let me think.
So for those listeners out there,
if any soil biologist know this well,
if you go out and get some nice rich
soil,
a of it and you analyze,
it typically is a million 5 million
microbes per gram in that soil.
Now the mycelium is growing out.
We have five or six skin layers that
protect us from infection.
The mycelium only has one cell wall on
the other side of that cell wall are
hundreds of millions of microbes per
gram that are trying to consume it.
Many of which the mycelium is able to
upregulate and constant biomolecular
communication with this ecosystem be
able to prevent predators from consuming
it,
thus allowing it to achieve the largest
mass of any organism in the world.
This is amazing to me because it means
that it is constantly in communication
with the ecosystem being challenged,
accepting alliances,
so guilds of microbiomes are being
created selected by the mycelium and
these guilds and communities then
cooperate in order to prevent pathogens,
parasites,
even competing guilds from coming into
that landscape.
So the dominance of these fungi are to
ensure the ecosystems give lives to
their progeny.
The rule of natural selection of life is
reproduction,
so everything steers towards
reproduction.
So from evolutionary biology point of
view,
what will that organism do to help
survive so he can reproduce and
reproduction through creating guilds of
communities of the microbiome using the
mycelial network as the structural
foundation of the food web seems to be
the name of the game here.
So this honey mushroom,
is that what it's called?
And that lives in the Pacific northwest.
It.
How is it killing these trees is a root
parasite,
so it comes in and kills the trees and I
spent a lot of time in the old growth
forest and a lot of hiking.
I've always been one wondering about
meadows and the sub Alpine regions.
There's all these subalpine forests and
then you come out and it is giant
meadows.
I suspect that the honey mushroom is a
meadow maker.
It climaxes these trees.
It kills them.
They then die and then they grow out
prophetically,
but then it clears the canopy for the
grasses landscape,
sap prophetic music.
It's growing on dead material,
so first is a parasite mushrooms,
the mushrooms,
the persons.
The parasite kills the tree.
That's a sacrifice or sap probe as
another word for it.
It's a decomposer.
It breaks down that material,
but as it decomposes the wood,
30 percent of wood becomes water,
so the mycelium generates water,
so water lenses are being created that
now you have more sunlight.
Grasses then flourish,
and so I suspected that these mushrooms
are actually meadow makers allowing then
the elk and the deer and marmots and
whatnot to exist in those grassland
environments as a way of rebuilding the
nitrogen sources in the soil.
So I think these are over great huge
time scales.
We have to get away from the concept of
our lifespan or even 100,
200 years.
We need to think in millennial terms
over many,
many millennia.
This is unbelievably fascinating.
The idea that they're sort of the
architects of their ecosystem.
They are the architects of our
existence.
This is something that there's a really
fantastic research that's come out in
the past two years.
I'm.
I'm a science ambassador,
flared AAA's,
the American Association of Science,
so I am a little bit out there,
but I'm really happy that I have so much
scientific support these days because a
lot of the things I've been talking
about for 20 years now,
well rooted and been proven.
One of the things that that has been so
fascinating to me,
and I'm still wrapping my mind around
this,
but you know,
the universe was created about 13 point
8 billion years ago from the Big Bang.
The earth coalesced out of star at us
about four point 5 billion.
The earliest records of life we have is
about three point 8 billion years ago.
Single cell,
single celled organisms,
but just recently in lava beds in South
Africa,
they found mycelium infused to the lava.
Two point 4 billion years ago now,
we split from fungi,
650 million years ago,
and then in Brazil this past year,
they found a fully intact,
apparently a fossilized mushroom
published in nature,
which is a very reputable scientific
journal,
and that one is one point 4 billion
years old.
So the oldest,
multicellular organism in the fossil
record today is this fungus in lava in
South Africa.
Two point 4 billion years ago,
a fully formed mushroom who had this
form grew,
was growing.
One point 4 billion years ago,
we were.
We separated from fungi.
Six hundred 50 million years ago.
Mushrooms had their form longer than
we've had our form by more than a
billion years here.
Jamie just pulled it up on the screen
here so we can take a look at it.
One from Brazil.
So this is the pause.
This though,
the image that you're familiar with,
the one that has just been published in
the past,
they have a great name that's a tongue
twister to pronounce this Gondwana.
Garris ids magnificence.
Why did they do that?
They do that to make people like me feel
stupid.
They don't have to graduate students
want to publish papers and said they get
invent names,
so it looks better if you have a long
Latin sounding name,
so,
but think of that.
Mushrooms had their form before we had
ours.
These are elders,
these are ancient organisms.
These are the really the the overlord
under lords of our ecosystem and I
suspect and as these neural networks,
they have more neural connections in the
mycelial mass over a thousand acres and
we have in our brain,
they are actually accumulating
knowledge,
genetic intelligence,
but I think that as time goes on,
I hope that we have to interface with
them because I think there is a.
There are many benefits of us
communicating with mycelium that can
give us rapid responses to kind of
Straw.
That's how they've evolved and we're now
the biggest walking catastrophe that I
know walking across the planet and we
need to engage these fungal allies for
the benefits that we need to put it into
play in order to prevent the loss of
biodiversity.
It seems like a communication gap would
be very hard to bridge that
communication gap.
I mean,
if we really did find a way to
communicate in some form with mushrooms,
like the concept of language,
like you were talking about,
just the idea of nature and intelligence
and these words that we have,
that we have these sort of concrete
definitions in our head that don't
really apply to some things that are
very,
very confusing to us.
Like the idea of fungal intelligence,
the idea that you could somehow or
another understand the language that
these things we want.
We don't even understand dolphin
language.
Well,
one classic example,
example,
the Japanese are so clever at this.
They,
there was a slime mold called Pfizer
polycephalum and they had a.
and this slime mold is very,
very good at navigating through mazes
and challenges.
I mean,
first to food wins is conservation of
energy as rewarded.
So you don't want to set this up.
They like it.
They did several experiments.
Fun.
Most fun.
One is they,
they designed a nutrient basically
nutrient like maze replicating,
um,
Tokyo and the Japanese subway system.
And so they started with Tokyo and they
put oats,
which is a nutritional source.
They inoculated what is on this basic
and aggre map with all the major cities,
the nodes around Tokyo,
and they then make each of those nodes
had a piece of oat on them was a source
of nutrition.
The main oat was where Tokyo was.
They inoculated it and then they let the
slime mold then grow,
and first it grew out randomly
exploratory Lee,
just like you would do if you're a
hunter or something or hunting on the
landscape,
looking for things,
and then after about 28 hours,
it reorganized itself in the most
efficient way possible and reorganized
the Japanese subway system in a more
efficient manner than it's designed
today.
Thus they said,
not me,
not Paul stamets.
This is a demonstration of cellular
intelligence.
So this is the tip of the proverbial
mycelial iceberg.
You know,
this is,
it has broad implications and I just
want people to suspend their disbelief
and this goes into it actually,
the evolution of human consciousness and
Terence Mckenna was a good friend of
mine.
I love Terence.
I especially love the last five years of
his life because he made fun of himself
so much.
Terence people took terence way too
seriously in many levels,
but as his brother Dennis,
which I think has been on your show a
couple times.
Yeah,
this is a great ally,
great scientists,
but you know,
Dennis said even if 10 percent of what
terence said was true is frigging
amazing and terence and Dennis both came
up with a stain stoned ape theory.
Now it's not a theory,
it's a hypothesis.
A hypothesis is speculative,
but cannot necessarily be as not yet
proven.
A theory is a hypothesis that has been
tested and proven with facts,
so I disagree with them and saying it's
not a theory,
it's a hypothesis,
but the hypothesis of the stone,
a part of the stoned ape,
which I think you've alluded to before,
is that with climate change and as the
savannas increased and our primate
ancestors came out of the forest
canopies,
there are tracking across the Savanna
and if you're a hunter,
what do you look?
You look for footsteps.
I mean,
look for Scott and the most significant
fleshy mushroom going out of poop in
Africa,
hippopotamus,
elephant,
deer,
antelope,
et cetera.
His last big events,
this is a very large mushroom.
You're hungry,
you're with your clan,
you consume it,
and then 20 minutes later you are
catapulted in this extraordinary
experience.
Psilocybin substitutes,
as serotonin becomes a better
neurotransmitter,
activates neurogenesis,
it causes new neurons to form new
pathways of knowledge.
So that's the stoned ape hypothesis,
and it speaks to a mystery that the
human brain,
basically the brain cavity doubled in
size in about 2 million years.
Some people say as less as to less than
200,000,
Homo sapiens run 200,000
years.
Homo sapiens arrived at 200,000
to 300,000
years ago.
It's a big gap.
It's a big gamble,
but science is like that.
So you want to be scientifically
accurate.
Here,
I need to show the extreme margins of
what's been estimated,
so we accept 2 million years that the
innocent shown in the fossil record.
This is true,
the oldest homo sapiens fossils are
300,000
years old now,
but we have a subtle suddenly doubling
of the human brain.
And with that,
our language centers increased our
ability to prognosticate,
to plan,
and there's no explanation for this
currently.
And even though we may not be able to
prove it,
I ask people to suspend their disbelief
for a second.
Now,
think of this.
Our primate ancestors are going across
the Savanna,
the injustice mushrooms as a clan,
massive input for anyone's eaten.
These mushrooms,
huge amounts of data's coming in,
fractal patterns.
Geometrical landscapes occur.
You have empathy,
you have greater courage.
You're fighting a saber,
save a saber,
tooth tiger,
you know,
one day you have a fear of it.
We know now from neurogenesis and the
extinction of the fear response that has
been clinically proven.
PSILOCYBIN allows you to re set and have
different neurological pathways to
respond to fear,
overcoming the fear,
conditioned response,
potentially ptsd.
And there's a lot of research on this
currently so,
but this one happened one time with one
hominid group.
Wouldn't happen two times,
10 times it happened,
millions and millions and millions and
millions of times over millions and
millions of years.
This leads to what I think is called,
should be called epigenetic
neurogenesis.
We know that there was a regeneration of
neurons.
We know that psilocybin substitutes as
Serotonin,
it opens the floodgates of the senses.
You have a lot more data coming in and
we know that he has extinction of the
fear response,
so if you're the leader of your clan,
you've had this traumatic event,
either war or cataclysm from
earthquakes,
whatever the case may be,
or encounter a saber,
tooth tiger,
whatever.
If you're the leader of that clan and
you can overcome your fear response,
you have courage and you have empathy.
Those are leadership skills.
I think we'd be able to take note of it.
People like to fall leaders who are
courageous and yet kind who they can
trust,
they'll have their best interests in
mind.
So I think this propelled,
I think as a lot is a very good
explanation.
It's an unprovable hypothesis,
but now we're at a junction for the net
and we're ready for the next quantum
leap in human consciousness.
I think psilocybin should be looked upon
as a nootropic vitamin and there's a
huge amount of interest in this.
Johns Hopkins University,
as you probably well know,
New York University,
Ucla,
elsewhere in Europe,
there's major clinical studies that have
been conducted in the past two years
showing exactly what I'm saying about
overcoming fear response,
neurogenesis,
overcoming ptsd.
This is now medically quite seriously
considered and something that I think
that we should explore under controlled
settings.
I'm not into partying with psilocybin
mushrooms,
so good.
I can understand that fear is going to
be here in an hour and a half and he's
the creator of shroom fest.
He's going to be very upset with your
idea that you shouldn't party with it.
Well,
I think there's greater benefit and
humanity.
I think these are serious tools.
California has it.
I'm sure you probably aware.
Wow.
There it's up for legalization.
Yeah.
I was really quite surprised by that.
All my work and to put some caveats
here,
I was.
All my work is covered by a drug
enforcement administration license.
I've published now four new species in
the genus philosophy,
including the most potent psilocybin
mushroom in the world called philosophy
as residents,
and to be clear,
folks,
nature provides.
I don't,
so I had my dea license,
I mean everyone I suspected was a dea
agent who came to me and wanted to get
some psilocybin but probably got set up
a bunch of times,
numerous times at all.
It was,
it,
was it a point.
It was pretty funny.
You know,
I had this one person that offered me
just huge amounts of money and I played
with them and I said,
no,
it's not enough.
And he offered me more and more money
presented with 200,
$300,000
and he and he was writing all these
coded letters.
Really obviously a dea agent trying to
set me up and finally got really
frustrated because I was playing with a
guy.
I said,
you know,
I'm tired of being set up like this.
I'm just gonna play with a Sucker,
you know?
And so it finally came to a point and
you've got really,
really frustrated.
You don't get mad at me.
He goes,
well,
how much money I go,
there's not enough money on this planet
for me to ever give you a soulless Ivan
mushroom.
So give it up.
So.
But if you say that's not enough money,
could that be taken as a negotiation?
Well,
not enough money on the planet.
I suppose.
Some aliens,
not enough money on the planet for not
enough money.
It was not enough money.
Right before that goes,
is telling you that like if you had like
a really loosely interpreting judge you
I suppose.
But I never committed a criminal act.
So isn't it sort of like a conspiracy
to.
I'm not a lawyer.
I wouldn't have.
I mean you have to keep things in
context.
I wouldn't play.
Maybe you're more courageous person when
it comes to that stuff than me.
Well at some point I just got frankly
pissed off and I'm playing with waste of
your time.
I'm going to play with you and I'm going
to reverse the tables.
So.
But in any event,
this is serious research and it's
something that unfortunately,
because it can be marginalized by the
party atmosphere and used as a party
drug.
There's a really amazing study that just
came out about five days ago.
It's a big data study.
Four hundred and 40,000
people.
Prisoners were surveyed over 10 years
and the Department of Human and health
services data bank,
and they found an amazing correlation if
you had in this patient and this
prisoners,
one experience with psilocybin in your
life,
one experience it reduced in that
population compared to the people who
did not take psilocybin mushrooms,
an 18 percent reduction in burglary and
larceny and up to a 27 percent reduction
in other crimes including violent
crimes,
so that phenomenal.
I actually got my numbers reversed,
is 27 percent reduction in burglary.
Eighteen percent reduction in violent
crime.
Now,
think of the damage not only to the
victims and the victims' families,
the court system,
the lawyers,
the collateral damage,
people being upset because they were
being criminalized in prison for
something you know,
for merely possessing psilocybin
mushrooms or something like that.
But think of the return on investment of
four to six hour experience creates a
lifetime benefit to society.
Reducing criminal activity by 18 to 27
percent.
This is phenomenal.
This is that this is something that can
help the health of our,
of our human psyche,
our of our,
of our social system,
of reducing trauma throughout our entire
society.
It's time for us to wake up and look at
this at a much more seasoned and
intellectual fashion than we have a
rational
not weighed down by the ideas of
mushrooms being a silly thing
and so I mean I have a few pet peeves
and I understand why people want to use,
but the word shroom just drives me
crazy.
Shroom,
fast strand this room fastest with all
due respect.
I understand,
but let's not be children about this.
Let's be adults.
You know,
you're a serious person.
I get it.
I,
I'm also in a non serious person on many
levels,
but I know when it comes to something
that is so powerful that is so
important,
let's not jeopardize its use medically
and the benefit society in the future by
appealing to the lowest common
denominator.
Let's be adults in the room on this.
I agree with you to a certain extent,
but I also think that it's got to be
incredibly frustrating for a guy like
you that has the kind of information
that you have bouncing around your head
in relationship to the rest of the
world.
Views it.
See to a person like myself who I don't
know nearly as much as you know,
but I know quite a bit more than the
average person when it comes to
psilocybin and mushrooms or Amanita
[inaudible] or Terence Mckenna's ideas.
Shroom fest doesn't bother me,
but for a serious researcher like
yourself,
it's got to be like,
oh,
you're a part of the problem.
Right?
Well,
it's naked.
It's silly.
Is that Timothy leary problem,
right?
Right.
It held back the bonafide research in
this subject for years.
There's a movement right now in that,
please.
It is.
There's a movement right now to move
psilocybin from schedule one to schedule
two,
schedule one illegal drug that has no
medical benefits.
Schedule two means it's a drug that has
medical benefits,
so there's a serious movement going on
right now within the FDA to have it be
recategorized because in the words of
FDA researchers,
I know one arm's length removed is that
they've never seen anything with such a
strong safety profile.
They give so much benefit at so little
cost for such a long time.
This is a drug in a category of its own.
This is really important.
Let's not jeopardize it.
It is really important,
but you're never going to stop kids from
calling a truce.
Well,
you know,
and I want to give a pass here.
I want to get a pass and the coming of
age,
you know,
when I was 16 to the age 20 to 24,
it's the coming of age ceremony.
Now I'm going to tell you something
that's very deeply personal and very
significant in my life.
I had a congenital stuttering habit.
I could not speak.
I could not look at Joe Rogan in the eye
right now without,
you know,
I had like the king's speech.
You've seen the movie exactly like that,
but worse.
In my case,
I went through six years of speech
therapy.
I was interviewed for special education.
I grew up in a small town called
Columbiana,
Ohio and I could not speak now the type
of stuttering habit that I have and had.
I don't stutter to animals.
I had pet snapping turtles and I haven't
talked to him all the time and I don't
stutter when I sing,
but I could not elocute without
stuttering constantly and please people
out there don't finish a stutterers
sentence.
The type of stutterer category that I
have been in is that we would try to
trick our brain with a prepositional or
adverbial phrase halfway through the
sentence that we're stuck on because
we're thinking three or four sentences
ahead and the only way you can do is
trick the brain.
So I had to come up with a new
neurological pathway to trick my brain
so I could get out of my stuttering
rhythm.
That was just repetition I couldn't get
out of.
And then in one day before I ever had
psilocybin mushrooms,
I bought some,
a bag of them and I thought I got,
I had no information,
I just bought the bag for about 25 bucks
and I went out for a walk in the woods
in Ohio and there was a beautiful oak
tree that I used to climb the top of the
very top of the tallest hill in Ohio.
We don't have mountains,
we have hills and it isn't a summertime.
And so I thought set and setting is
important.
I knew that.
So I went for a walk and I ate the bag,
the whole bag when I was walking.
How many announcers you think?
Well,
it was about.
I know it was about a half an ounce to
an ounce.
So.
So we're,
we're talking.
This is,
this is,
this is the elevator ride beyond the
10th floor.
So eight to 16 grams is probably on the
order,
about 20 grand,
you know.
So.
And,
but I didn't know.
No,
I had no one to.
So.
But I knew that I went to this.
I want to.
My destination was this tree.
So I walked and walked and I came at the
tree and I was eating the mushrooms and
then I started feeling the effects and
so it was great because I was climbing
the tree and I was getting higher in the
tree and higher in my brain.
Well that seems like a terrible thing to
do.
And I climbed to the top of the tree and
this beautiful landscape.
But it was,
was the summertime,
these boiling black clouds in the
horizon.
I go,
oh,
that's cool.
You know?
And so this big summer storm was coming.
The,
the clouds were dark and boiling and,
and they're coming close and I could
hear the thunder and you know,
and then I'm going to higher and higher
and the winds pick up and the tree
started moving and I started getting
vertigo because I was like,
oh my God,
I'm getting so freaking high on these
mushrooms.
And so I grabbed the tree and held on
the tree and it became my axis Mundi
into the earth.
And then the lightning started coming
closer and then lightning strikes
started.
I'm really close and the lightning would
hit and I saw fractals for the first
time the atmosphere became liquid.
I saw this liquid waves of these
multidimensional geometrical patterns
everywhere and the sparks of lightning
would just create these amazing
crescendos of secondary,
tertiary fractals all around me and I
was like,
oh my.
It was amazing.
I said,
this is what I read about.
So the storm came and lightning strikes
are all around me and I was washed with
rain ends up there and I felt I felt in
touch with Gaia,
the universe.
My heart opened up.
I felt one with all.
I was like,
oh my gosh,
this is such a powerful spiritual
experience.
I had no idea.
No matter what anyone has read,
as you probably know it cannot describe
the experience,
and then it dawned on me,
wait a second,
stamets,
you're in the tallest tree on the
tallest hill for miles in the middle of
a lightning storm.
This is not the best place to be,
and so I realized I could be killed up
here.
Suddenly I had a reality rush,
like you could turn into a god.
Imagine like Comic Book,
Twenty Grams of mushrooms,
hugging a tree,
the lightning comes and hits you and
maybe you were the savior.
Maybe you need to get back to that tree.
Maybe you're the chosen one.
So I thought it was an incredibly
spiritual and wonderful experience,
but I also had the fear,
and this comes,
comes with the hero's journey,
you know,
you always have the dark side.
He always have not just the light side,
but it's counterbalanced the dark side.
Then I realized,
oh my gosh,
I'm gonna.
I could die up here and said,
well,
I don't die stamets,
which were your issues?
This,
this gets something out of this
experience.
And I said,
this stuttering habits ridiculous and
I'm not stupid.
So I said to myself,
stop stuttering now.
Stop Stuttering now.
I said that dozens hundreds of times
over and over and over,
and fortunately the storms went past and
held onto the tree and soaking wet.
I came out of the tree and walked back
to where I was living in the next day I
got up,
I didn't see anybody and I was walking
on on on this path and sidewalk and
there's a lady that I really liked a
lot,
but she was always attracted to the
super self assured jocks and things like
that.
She was actually very kind and sweet,
but I didn't want to stare at her in the
eyes because I would stutter and it's
humiliating for us,
so the more humiliating us stutterers
feel,
the more we stutter and so it's a really
slippery slope and so I would avoid eye
contact and so for the first time she
walked towards him,
he says,
Good Morning Paul,
how are you?
She was always so nice to me and I was
terrified because embarrass myself,
and I looked at her straight in the eyes
and I said,
I'm doing fine.
How are you?
And I stopped stuttering in one day and
this speaks to now.
What has been medically proven is that
we can reset the neurology of the human
brain through neurogenesis.
I believe that experience allowed me to
map new neurological pathways that
allows me to elocute in a way that I
could not elocute before.
Now,
just to be truthful here,
if I drink a lot of alcohol,
I'm in a loud bar because us stutterers,
you're a martial artist.
I've been a martial artist all my life
and we have peripheral consciousness and
so if someone comes through a door,
you know,
into the bar and I'm looking at you.
I know that they've come through,
so this hyper alertness that US martial
artists have of knowing things in the
circumference around us in the
peripheral environment is distracting.
So if I drink a lot and there's a loud,
a loud noise and a lot of people coming
in and out of doors,
I'm hypersensitive to intruders and then
that's when I'll start stuttering.
If the person's talking to me asking me
how do you grow mushrooms?
It's like filling a well with a teaspoon
because I'm worried about the guy who
just came through the door over there
who looks like he may not be a safe
person to be in this environment right
now.
So that there's a time that I'll,
you only give 10 percent of my brain to
communicating to the person in front of
me.
My 90 percent of my brain is hyper aware
in the circumstantial environment around
me,
time for another trip to the tree to
cure that last 10 percent.
But that's my personal story.
That's amazing and it's not going to
work.
But it worked for you.
That's what's important for me.
And I was at crater lake lodge and a
waiter came up to me and he goes,
he's about 17,
18 years of age,
a bus boy actually.
And my wife and I,
my wife looked at me and I looked,
looked at her and I said,
should I?
Yeah,
go ahead.
So I told her,
I told this bus boy at the same story.
Now this guy was totally straight,
looked like it was a super conservative
from a super conservative family.
And we told him this whole story and his
eyes were wide open because when you
meet other stutterers and you talk to
them,
they're really desperate for a solution.
So I never knew what happened to this
young bus boy.
But I think I changed his life forever.
I hope you did.
So I had a good friend growing up and
his brother was severely stricken with
it to the point where he would have to
wince,
close his eyes and looked down and he
would talk to you and he just couldn't
get over it.
It was.
But he won't stutter to animals.
It won't stutter when he sings.
So what do you think it is?
Like what is.
What is happening?
Do you think that?
Well,
there's several things.
It could be trauma when you're a child
combined with neuropathy.
I was told by one psychiatrist who is a
specialist in this at a conference that
there is a theory that in the seventh or
eighth month in the womb,
you,
your neurons failed to make all the
connections that it to.
So that makes sense to me because why
would reroute with preposition
preposition or adverbial phrases to try
to jump around the little habitual loop
that I'm in.
But I think this speaks to increasing
intelligence and we all will suffer from
some form of dementia and neuropathy
occurs.
There is a really wonderful,
safe and legal mushroom to use that at
least in neurogenesis and that's called
lion's mane.
And Lion's mane is a cascading white
icicle edible choice mushroom.
They sell in the stores,
the stores,
grocery stores all over.
Yeah,
lion's Mane.
They're called,
um,
various brand names.
One I love is called pom Pom Blanc.
It looks like pom poms from cheerleaders
and lion's mane contains a unique group
of compounds called rna scenes and
herbicide nuns.
And these regenerate Myelin on the axons
of nerves.
And so this is a mushroom [inaudible]
discovered this in 1994,
a Japanese researcher and he postulated
it as a potential preventative or
treatment for Alzheimer's,
muscular dystrophy,
etc.
But do take it.
I take it every day,
every day,
every day.
Take it in raw form or I take it in
capsules.
So you Buy it?
Yeah,
we have a,
we have an extensive product line.
How do you get to that host defense.com,
host defense.com.
Why host defense?
And that's part of your innate immunity
response,
supporting your immunity.
But our main business is@fungi.com.
And I mentioned that many myself,
I'm kind of proud of that.
It cost me 25 bucks.
Nineteen 94.
Wow.
You were ahead of the ball so well
yourself,
but lIon's mane is a safe mushroom to
consume.
There are several clinical studies out
on treating mild cognitive dysfunction,
but there's two mouse studies that I
think are quite illustrative and this is
translational medicine.
This translates from mice experiments to
humans.
We already know is that it has aspects
of neurogenesis.
When you go into all zimmer,
a state of alzheimer's,
which is a bit complex,
but one of the characteristics is the
formation of amyloid plaques.
De myelination of the neurons.
Myelin transmits the neural signals,
demyelination occurs.
Your outer sheath on the neurons is
interrupted by amyloid plaques that then
prevent neurotransmission.
So the experiments with the mice,
which I think are so interesting was one
experiment was the the maze experiment
where the mice were put into an arena
and they went out of the corridor and
they went one way in the corridor or
they'd find food the other way.
There's no food.
Well,
very quickly the mice learned,
you know,
you go out the corridor,
go to the left,
you find food,
they injected it.
Then with a toxic polypeptide that
induces amyloid plaque formation.
That is a neurotoxin.
very quickly after two weeks or so,
the mice developed neuropathy.
They got confused.
They couldn't remember which way to go
at randomized.
Upon giving these mice again,
mushrooms for a few weeks,
they nearly read,
normalized upon sacrificing the mice.
And the first part of the experiment,
they saw the amyloid plaques and the de
myelination.
The second part of the experiment,
of course,
another subset of mice,
they found that the myelin regrew and
the amyloId plaque had resolved.
this is postmortems by say 100 miles.
You're basically cutting their brains
cutting off a representative sample is
sacrifice them.
You determine,
yeah,
that's representative of the population.
Now,
the remaining population as alive,
they fed them the mushrooms and they
found that they regained neurological
function.
The other experiment,
which I find is even more fun is,
um,
and this was done in Japan.
They put like 100 mice in an arena and
they put a toy in the middle of the
cage.
All the mice got excited,
they came up and sniffed it and smelled
it,
and they got really excited and they sat
there with counters to measure the
number of points of contact,
how many points of contact the mice have
exploring a new toy,
so they got a really good baseline,
hundreds of data points,
and then did the same thing.
Then they introduced thiS peptide,
this neurotoxin,
and the mice.
Then after awhile were uninterested,
didn't have imagination,
no curiosity.
They put a new toy.
They were disinterested.
They did the same thing.
Now even their full blown dementia like
symptoms gave them lion's mane
mushrooms,
and after a few weeks where they put it
in a new toy,
they came back to near normal levels.
Upon sacrificing the mice,
they found that the amyloid plaque had
resolved and myelin had regenerated and
neurogenesis had occurred.
This is a smart mushroom.
Now.
The tragedy that we face,
I believe as a society is we have people
like yourself,
people like me,
we're all going to suffer through
neuropathy.
We have a lifetime of a body intellect
of knowledge that we're going to start
losing.
So what is the loss to society of our
elders?
Forgetting not remembering.
So I think this is something that's
reallY extraordinarily exciting.
It's not patentable,
it's the drug companies have no interest
in this,
but this is probably the number one
thing that people can do in my mind to
present,
to preserve cognitive function,
but to expand it now,
I personally would love to see it legal,
to stack them both together,
stacking psilocybin with lion's mane,
and I think that stacking thing and then
combining it with vitamin d three.
Now by suggest vitamin d three niacin
because those of you who've had a niacin
flush,
you know,
200 milligrams of niacin or more,
you get red,
you get itchy and neuropathy typically
is presented at the fingertips at the
end of your toes and your fingers and
your peripheral nervous system.
as you have neuropathy,
the nerve endings begin to die
backwards,
so my idea here is because there are
different receptors being activated by
psilocybin than with the [inaudible]
from lion's mane.
If you stack lion's mane with psilocybin
mushrooms with niacin.
The advantages of this is hypothetical,
but this is something I think is well
worth testing is that niacin can help
drive the neurogenic benefits of
psilocybin and aaron means to the end of
the peripheral nervous system.
So we actually have a planning right
now,
clinical study in Oregon with lion's
mane mushrooms.
The physicians who've looked at the
research which is robust,
are convinced that it adds worthy and
they have their own funding.
So we're going to have 30 study is what
we hope to do,
30 patients and we hope to begin that
study in the next year.
It was phenomenal to see how that would
affect people with cte.
People like football players,
boxers,
people with,
uh,
across,
across the board.
The benefits.
And this is something that when you're
depressed,
you're not creative and your immune
system is depressed as well.
You're psychologically emotionally
depressed and you're not as creative
when you are happy,
you are creative and your immune system
is better.
So this could be fundamental to disease
mitigation across the board.
So tHis is some of the.
This is,
there are so many different examples
like this where mushrooms need to be
advanced to the front stage of
consideration by serious scientists and
give up your michael phobia or even your
silo phobia,
the irrational fear of psilocybin
mushrooms and look upon these with new
eyes and drop your prejudices and just
look at as a serious scientific
analysis.
Wow.
how is this received?
Like in the general scientific
community?
Is there skepticism?
I love my skeptics because unless
they're prejudice against you,
some people are.
You can never convince them,
but if scientists,
when they see the data sets and they see
there's a dozen or more publications
with scientists without commercial
interests who've done this
independently,
then it's being taken very seriously.
So though the whole medical community
right now,
you know,
I speak at a number of medical
conferences at ted med,
the american academy of dermatology,
of the keynote speakers.
Many medical conferences.
And,
and it's great because I can take people
who are totally skeptical and most of
them walk out of that room convinced,
and why shouldn't we think that fungi
are sources of medicines.
I mean,
penicillin may have tipped World war ii
in our favor.
So the job,
the japanese and germans did not have
panelists penicillin,
even though Alexander Fleming discovered
it in 1928 in 1941,
a lab tech researcher went to a market
in chicago,
found a moldy cantaloupe,
and alexander fleming's strain of
penicillin was too weak.
It couldn't be commercialized.
This lady researcher who found this
moldy cantaloupe found a penicillium
strain that was 200 times more potent.
And as a result of that,
in war,
the most of the casualties died from
infections.
And so the british and the english,
the english and the americans had
penicillin.
The germans and japanese did not.
And so it is.
There's a great npr analysis on this,
on the history of penicillin,
and it is one of the major factors in
helping tilt the balance in the favor of
the allied powers against the axis
powers so concerned with the researchers
in england.
They impregnated their clothes with
spores of this mold strain.
So if our laboratories were bombed or
they were captured,
if one of them escaped,
they could regenerate the culture from
their clothing.
Whoa.
Wow.
And this speaks to the panspermia.
We're all carrying microbiomes of fungi.
The fact that you and I are here
together means that I have now
inoculated you with my microbiome of
selected fungi.
So joe,
you are now a vector.
Whoa,
awesome.
Congratulations.
Now does the frustrating aspects of.
What is the word that you use?
Fungi phobiA.
So we used by co phobia,
michael phobia.
The frustrating aspects are first of
all,
prohibition,
right?
Sweeping psychedelic act of 1970 that
made psilocybin mushrooms illegal.
Right?
And then on top of it,
the commercial pharmaceutical industry,
which doesn't want to have anything to
do with anything that it can't patent
and has so many doctors and so many
researchers in its pocket.
So you have two issues there,
right?
You have one issue that people,
which is obviously why you don't like
the word shroom.
People think of mushrooms as a party
drug of like being silly,
freaking out,
doing something stupid,
regrettable actions.
And then afterwards going,
wow,
we got so crazy.
I was thinking of it as a frivolous sort
of thing that you would engage in.
Whereas what you're trying to do is show
the absolute hard science.
Do you feel that this absolute hard
science is.
I mean,
you must feel that it's unfairly
inhibited and hindered.
The sun has been,
but there's never been a title change.
Uh,
and um,
pharma ecology of the use psilocybin and
um,
and its utility as a therapeutic agent
is there's a title change.
I think now there's over 700 patients
have gone through johns hopkins clinical
trials for things like end of life,
add depression,
ptsd.
There's studies out on treating
alcoholics.
And drug addicts,
so and this is important to communicate
to people.
In John Hopkins study in particular,
dr roland griffiths,
a great,
great scientist.
He's been running and championing these
studies,
came up with a very interesting series
of analyses and some of the take home
points were only 70 percent of the
people described the psilocybin
experience therapeutically under
controlled settings at John Hopkins with
a very high dose of psilocybin as being
beneficial.
Only 70 percent,
70 percent.
Thirty percent of them saying,
I didn't like that,
but in a retrospective study,
14 months to two years later,
the 70 percent of the people who said it
was a beneficial experience,
still described it as one of the most
significant beneficial experiences of
their lifetime and interviewing their
friends,
their spouses.
They saw a permanent residual effect
from the benefits of the experience.
There were nicer people.
They're nicer to get along.
They're less prone to anger.
They had many of values that we would
cherish as an improved community of
individuals.
The 30 percent of the people who had a
negative experience,
the negativity of the experience did not
extend Beyond the experience themselves,
so they didn't have collateral damage
where we had collateral benefit,
so the positive people saw that as a
positive experience and the memory of
the experience.
This is so cool.
The memory of the experience kept them
optimistic,
hopeful,
and they felt benefits from just
remembering the experience that people
had a negative experience.
They just wouldn't do that again.
So these mushrooms are obviously not for
everyone,
but for the people who do benefit,
they benefit substantially.
Don't you feel
a lot of the people that have those
negative experiences,
at least from my understanding,
a lot of it are people that have some
serious issues that they're not dealing
with and ego problems and the mushrooms
expose that and they tried to wrestle
the mushroom.
I mean when.
Absolutely.
I think the very well put.
I think that's a big issue.
Some people are afraid of their inner
self.
They know we're all.
He can't paint the canvas,
black and white.
We're a big spectrum of complex
personality traits and what happens to
somebody when they're two years old,
five years old,
what trauma they experience,
you know,
it's very complex to be able to make the
savings,
but I think as a,
as a group,
there are some people who are on the
edge and they may not control their
innermost emotions and they're afraid of
that in normal state of consciousness.
So they're Afraid they might lose their
control.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean I've,
I've had personally some terrIfying
psychedelic experiences,
but the way I've gotten through them is
just to give in,
just to give in and for a person like
myself was kind of a control freak,
especially when I was younger.
It's a hard thing to do to use because
you're like,
no,
I'm going to be fine.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck this.
You know,
I'm going to know that I don't like
where this is going.
I'm going to stop this right now.
I'm going to put a halt to this.
I bring myself back to sobriety like
it's impossible.
It's not going to happen.
So you have to figure out how to just
let go and how to just really let go and
trust the mushroom or the dmt or
whatever it is that you're on to take
you on this ride and you'll be okay when
it's over.
And if you can't do that,
that's the bad trIp.
And I've seen a lot of people have bad
trips.
We'll say close friends.
We.
We are the casualty of the fact that we
don't have an infrastructure tradition
in our societies like first peoples and
native americans too.
They have set up a structure.
They have a tradition shamanically your
mind,
traditions,
rituals,
elders.
They have done this for a long time.
I have set and setting down.
They know how to treat these powerful
medicines in the right context and we
lack that.
You did,
you know that mushrooms were
specifically banned from beer in the
bavarian beer act of 15,
16,
whoa.
And mushrooms and hen bane and other
plants were used in meads psychoactive
beers and celebrated by people
practicing pagan religions in europe,
in the forest.
And the struggle between,
I believe christianity,
monotheism versus polytheism and nature
based religions.
There was a collision course and then
under pressure of the church,
they banned the addition of these plants
that could be your gateway to god
because the church wanted to be in
between you and god.
They wanted to get the tIthings.
They wanted to be your portal and
control,
access to the divine,
and so these mushrooms are looked upon
as being specifically a threat to
monotheism and christianity.
So the the very end beer act banned
mushrooms.
That's incredible.
Terence had some pretty interesting
ideas about that.
Terence mckenna did one of the things
that he said that he believed that as
the climate changed and some mushrooms
became less and less available,
they started preserving them in honey
because you can preserve things in honey
and that in preserving things in honey,
you also run into the possibility of
fermented honey and then fermented honey
becoming mead.
You go into more of an alcohol culture
than a psychedelic culture,
which is really like on the opposite end
of the spectrum.
Alcohol culture is loosened inhibitions,
wild behavior,
less thought of the consequences of your
actions,
less introspective,
thinking much more chaos,
right,
and that he believes that this has
probably resulted in some sort of a
shift he believed rather before he
passed,
that was resulted in some sort of a
shift from these more communal mushroom
worshiping cultures to what you saw like
in the inquisition and some of the more
chaotic times in history.
I would respectfully disagree with the
secoNd part of that analysis,
not what you're saying,
but what terence would have been saying.
Mushroom being preserved in honey as a
way of preventing them from rotting.
Do with mead.
Well you did.
I think it did have something to do with
me,
but the amount of alcohol being produced
versus the dose that you would get.
It seemed to me this all simon dose Will
be so much more powerful than the small
amount of alcohol you'd be trying.
Am I misrepresenting what he was saYing?
No,
I don't think so.
I think you're.
You're,
you have.
You just disagree with his initial idea
and that's,
that's okay.
You know,
terence isn't terence is,
it was a very smart guy and I still
appreciate and love him wandering
thoughts and they were amazing,
but his time timewave zero was totally
bs,
so that was crazy.
That was crazy.
He had the end of time occurring on his
birthday.
I go,
don't you think that's a little
egocentric?
No.
Well,
he also had some strange sort of a
computer program and I've tried to
follow it many,
many times.
Some of the lectures that he gave on
that computer program that represented
timewave zero,
the idea was for people interested,
he just thought there was going to come
a point of ultimate novelty and somehow
or another conveniently he had that
point coinciding with both his birthday
and the end of the mayan calendar.
Right?
Yeah.
His birthday was december 20,
first 2012 as well.
I think so.
Yeah.
But the other thing to celebrate totally
egotistical,
I,
I loved him,
but he basically got the math to conform
to the convenience of his birthday.
So it's like
whatever.
We're all guilty of being human.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean even the great ones.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he was a great,
he was one of my favorite people in
terms of like listening to his
recordings.
Do you ever listen to psychedelic salon?
Oh yeah.
Amazing.
One of the best articulators of the
english language I've ever.
Yes.
So yeah,
I agree.
And as is his brother.
Yeah.
Every time is how,
which what brings me back to the stoned
ape theory.
One of the things that his brother
talked about,
and maybe you could elaborate on this,
was the impact that psilocybin has on
the creation of language and he thinks
that the very pathways that you were
discussing that psilocybin sort of
empowers that,
that may very well have been how human
beings started elaborating on language.
Oh,
I think he's correct on that because a
glossary leo,
um,
and we know the neurogenesis occurs in
the hippocampus.
Gloss eylea is the ability to speak and
elocute languages and new words as
languaging.
Your ability to language is increased
under the experience of psilocybin.
Speaking to neurogenesis and exactly
what we've been talking about,
is that basically your hippocampus is
your center for learning and memory and
is why the mice got better because
neurogenesis was occurring in the
hippocampus and so they regained their
memory and they were able to learn.
And so yes,
I think this neurogenesis not only
occurs in the hippocampus,
but I think it can also occur in the
peripheral nervous system of an
extraordinarily powerful story that I
would like to tell about neurogenesis
and um,
it was from a good friend of mine named
bill webb.
He lived in big sur California.
He was a friend of ansell adams and
Henry Miller who wroTe copic tropic of
capricorn,
whatever it was in the sixties.
This is a big part of the movement in
the sixties and seventies and antal
items is the very famous photographer.
And bill webb was a mentor to me.
I met him in 20 years of age.
I was writing.
I wrote my first book,
philosophy,
mushroom,
mushrooms,
and our allies.
You wrote your first book at 20 axiom?
I was 18.
You bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
It was the weirdest.
I mean,
I haven't told anyone this in 30 years,
but I went up to a place called Montana
books in seattle and I had my manuscript
and I walked into the bookstore because
I was told Montana books was a kind of
an avant garde book publisher in the
early 19 seventies.
And so I was told to go up there and I
made an appointment and then I go in,
I'm meeting with a publisher and he
goes,
listen,
this is an interesting little field
guide you wrote,
but this is not our market.
You know,
you really need a book representative.
You need an agent.
And he said,
the best agent I know by far is bill
webb,
you know,
but I haven't seen bill webb in two
years,
but you know,
you really need to see bill webb.
And when he said those words,
the door opened,
a little bell rang.
And in walked bill webb,
he was like,
the publisher goes,
this is freaking crazy,
you know?
So building a webinar,
I became tightly bonded.
He was a father figure to me.
He was in his seventies when I met him.
So bill and I went down to big sur and
we tripped together,
was a great mentoring father,
son relationship and bill and I became
very tight and then bill was about 82
years of age and he calls me up and he
says,
paul,
I have to tell you something that's so
important and I want you to listen so
you understand paul.
I go,
yeah,
bill,
hi,
how are you doing?
He goes,
well,
not doing too well.
I'm losing my sight.
I'm losing my hearing and getting a
getting old sucks.
He said,
but I want to tell you something that's
really important.
You know,
great.
bill hasn't tell me to know.
Paul,
I want you to absolutely swear to me.
You will tell this to other people.
I go,
got it,
bill.
I said,
okay,
bill,
you've laid.
I made the promise.
What is it?
He goes,
okay,
I've had this fricking hearing aid and I
hate it.
I can't hear the birds or the waves
breaking on the beach.
And that's a big part of the big sur
experience live above the cliffs of big
sur.
And I said,
well,
what w w,
w how this relate?
And he goes,
well,
I did a five gram dose of cubensis.
That's the hero's journey for people who
are listening.
Five grams is,
is is it,
you know,
you're on the floor,
and was on his deck and it was house in
and he noticed that he dIdn't.
his hearing aid,
he could hear the birds in the waves and
things like that.
And he's laying there just.
He's like 80,
80,
mid eighties at that point.
And he's just like having this
incredibly blissful experience.
He's coming there to reconcile his own
mortality.
The fact that he's going to die,
he's thinking about his life and he's
kind of dreaming in that dreamscape.
And he hears,
click,
click.
He looks around and he goes,
what's that noise?
He shakes his ear.
Maybe something is click,
click,
click.
He looks around and he decided,
he's driving me crazy.
I go,
where's the sound coming from?
And he finally looked over and it was
ants walking on the deck by near his
head.
He could hear their footsteps.
Neurogenesis.
Jesus christ,
and this is an easily measurable metric,
silicide and experienced while he was
fully on the experience,
he said he did not use a hearing aid for
three or four days.
Now I've mentioned this today,
just do mushrooms again and keep the
hearing.
Well,
that's basically he ran out of cubensis
and so hearing he was asking me for
cubensis and that's.
I'm sorry I can't get provided.
So I've mentioned this now to several of
the clinical researchers who have dea
licensed or doing clinical research.
This is an easily measurable metric you
can do as people were fully,
you know,
in these sessions they could be giving
them auditory stimulation to see if the
auditory nerve is undergoing regena
neurogenesis and so this is something
that I think that can be incorporated in
the clinical studies to see if this is
true.
But bill was emphatic and when bill webb
spoke,
he had enormous gravitas.
This guy was a serious intellectual.
So I think this is a end of one study,
one individual,
but I think this is something that
medical researchers did you pay
attention to.
What do you think could possibly
regenerate anything that quickly though,
like how could it happen so quickly that
during the excited for our trip,
because they're like nodes of crossing
and there's an interconnectedness that
occurs and there's a great graphic which
I didn't send you an advance showing
this is your brain without psilocybin.
This is your brain will whistles simon,
and there's a massive amount of neural
connections that are occurring.
so I think,
um,
you know,
the,
just like water chooses the path of
least resistance.
I think that neurologically,
if,
if there is a neurological pathway that
can help you as a species,
as an individual survive,
should there be a saber tooth tiger on
the horizon,
then I think that the economy of energy
in nature would reward the neurological
pathways that are most likely to lead to
your survival.
So I think that neurogenesis across the
brain occurred just like me with my
stuttering and there was another
neurological pathway.
BuT in bill's case,
when he lost his access to those
mushrooms,
the neuropathy became more resident and
prominent.
And so what we're looking at these
images mean we just put jamie's the
best.
We're just,
we're looking at these images.
And could you explain to us what these
are?
This is your brain on magic mushrooms.
Exactly.
Opposite of nancy reagan's mantra here.
Yeah,
this is.
You can push this up to your faces.
The,
the placebos on the left.
This is your normal representation of
interconnectedness between the nodes of
your brain.
So I try to explain this to people.
most of the people are just listening
rather than viewing.
Okay.
So the,
the one on the left,
it basically shows the connections
between neuronal nodes that maybe on the
order of 40 or 50 different nodes of
crossing.
The one on the right with psilocybin is
literally in the hundreds and the nodes
of crossing not only are more of them,
but the thickness of the lines speaks to
how robust those nodes are crossing are
for carrying neurological signals.
So this is pretty amazing.
Now,
this also influences,
I think is important for our us
military,
you know,
for,
for coders,
for people who are trying to solve very
complex data sets.
The ability of you to have increased
cognition and increased intelligence,
and this is why microdosing is the rage
in silicon valley.
Enormous number of coders are
microdosing right now and for those who
are listening,
this loose use philosophy cubensis as
the standard species because that's the
one that's mostly grown and at a half a
gram to a quarter gram you have lift
off.
Five grams is the full blown hero's
journey.
A lot of people will take between two
and four grams as a moderately spiritual
experience.
Four grams being higher and so
microdosing is is taking a dose so low
that if at most you might feel it a
little bit giddy the first time you take
it the first day,
but you build up a tolerance
immediately.
The second day,
second day you feel nothing.
So that's on the order of a 10th of a
gram of cubensis Where people are taking
this and then they're taking it
repeatedly over time and coders in
silicon valley from the biggest computer
companies that we all know.
This is a not only a fashion but a tool
that they are seeing an increased
ability for coming up with codes and as
a competitive advantage in the
capitalistic system.
I have a good friend who's a world
champion kickboxer and one of the best
in the world.
He microdose is daily and he's been
doing it over the last leg,
I want to say probably year or so,
and he.
He has achieved phenomenal improvements
in his performance.
Because of that.
He says that when he's sparring,
it's almost like he's psychic,
like he knows what people are going to
do before they do it.
He said his mood is better.
He feels better.
He just feels more balanced and he'll
take days off and when he takes days off
and even though he's completely sober
while he's microdosing because he's
really only microdosing.
There's something about taking days off
Where everything just feels like kind of
shitty,
just doesn't feel good.
And then he's like,
oh,
I didn't.
I didn't take my microdose.
And so he takes it again and goes right
back to that place,
but he feels like he's in the matrix.
Well,
actually it's probably good that he
interrupts it because it washes those
receptors clean of this all,
simon and the time.
Do you think you should interrupt for
two days out of out of seven,
so five days on,
two days off.
Now I'm not making official
recommendations.
I'm just saying from from my my small
amount of knowledge on the subject,
I.
I think that makes sense and that's
consistent with traditional chinese
medicine.
It's also consistent for those of us who
drink coffee like myself.
You drink coffee for five days,
you take two days off.
That next day is the strongest cup of
coffee you've had in a long time.
Me and my friends who are just coming to
the next podcast after this,
we just got done doing sober october.
So no alcohol,
no marijuana,
no nothing.
We drank coffee but that's it.
And when I stopped smoking marijuana,
the first thing that happened is my
dreams became rocket charged.
Like very biZarre,
like crazy,
lucid,
strange,
weird dreams.
Not lucid in the sense that controlled
them,
but lucid in the sense that I realized I
was dreaming and I was just like having
incredibly vivid,
vibrant dreams and I would wake up from
them and be certain that what I had done
was real.
Like I had one dream that I fell Asleep
on the couch and why I did fall asleep
on the couch.
But while I was asleep I was like,
oh,
I'm struggling to get this blanket over
me while I'm on the couch and I'm
pulling it,
but it's stuck under the cushions and
I'm struggling and I kinda halfway got
it over me and I went to sleep again.
Well,
when I woke up in the morning,
there was no blanket.
There's no blanket anywhere near me.
Didn't exist.
I had a lucid dream about covering
myself with a blanket while I was
sleeping on this couch.
Very strange and very primal dreams too.
Like being chased by wolves and running
into bears in and really bizarre,
very,
very vibrant colors.
And,
and apparently from what I've read,
marijuana does something to suppress rem
sleep and that in taking time off of it,
your,
your rem sleep just gets jacked through
the roof.
You know,
I've heard this many,
many times,
I've never seen in a clinical study on
it,
but it's that type of thing.
You hear so many times that you have
pretty good confidence that this is
true.
well,
we all experienced it.
All my friends who did it experienced at
ari in particular probably smokes as
much as I do,
maybe more.
I'm he experienced it deeply.
I'm glad that you mentioned lucid dreams
because this is a nice segue to I think
the greatest discovery I've made up my
life and I want us all came through a
lucid dream.
So let me,
let me set the stage here.
And a colony collapse disorder is a
threat to worldwide food,
biosecurity,
and killing bees.
Bees around the world are being
decimated.
Say the name of the disorder again,
colony collapse disorder disorder.
Now bees are dying off in enormous
quantities.
Oklahoma lost 85 percent of his beehives
last year or this 2016,
2017.
The annual loss of bees report and
Maryland lost 75 percent.
Nebraska I think lost 60 percent.
I met a beekeeper in Washington state
who lost 75 percent of his 35,000
hives.
Now apex mila for is the honeybee and
this factory farm now and the almond
harvest in California is the biggest
market for beekeepers who send their
bees to the almond orchards.
One bee component,
a thousand flowers and a day,
so every flower that bee visits is an
almond,
so it's one of the most bee dependent
crops in the world.
Thirty five percent of your food is
directly dependent upon bee pollination.
The other 65 percent,
much of that is indirectly dependent,
but hay,
alfalfa and clover for cows.
All of our dairy is dependent upon bee
pollination.
All of our berries,
all of our nuts,
coffee is even cannabis and other non
dependent plants benefit from what's
called buzz pollination because the bees
then can spread the pollen better
through the error.
It is now a thought by many of the
entomologist I've been dealing with,
that we could have full colony collapse
across the world within 10 years.
The cost,
it will be astronomical to our society.
Prices where food will raise poverty
will increase.
You could make the argument that
increased poverty leads to terrorism
because people are poorer,
they're desperate,
and so colony collapse now is much worse
than most people realize because all the
wild bees have now been infected.
So 80 percent of pollination services
come from wild bees and 20 percent from
managed honeybees.
Eva's [inaudible] is from a honey bee
from europe,
brought over in the 17 hundreds in 1984.
The varroa mite was introduced in the
United States and the varroa mite has is
like a is a parasite on the backs of
bees and injects viruses and
particularly the deformed wing virus,
the lake sinai virus,
and the black queen cell virus.
The Deformed wing virus is the really
the most important one.
Bees used to go and they only live 30
days,
but now they used to go pollinating for
nine days,
so they leave the hive and they
pollinate for about nine days.
I'd bring back pollen and uh,
that's their service to the hive and
they die off.
Now the average time for pollination is
only four days.
The order to fight the mites,
they've been using a toxic insecticide
called emma.
EMma tries.
Fights is licensed for fighting ticks on
cattle using cattle strength doses of
ama tries off label.
Beekeepers have been drenching their
hives with amtrust twice per year.
Now the mites have built up tolerance
and now they're up to nine times a year.
They're soaking the hives in order to
kill the mites because mites are
injecting these viruses.
This is all hands on deck.
This is the proverbial shit's gonna hit
the fan on.
This is an extremely important and
interestingly,
it's the number one bridge issue between
liberals and conservatives.
So when you're at thanksgiving dinner or
christmas or hanukkah,
if you want to avoid talking about trump
and politics and hillary or benghazi or
whatever that subject,
you know,
dispute is.
Talk about bees.
Everyone's on board on protecting the
bees.
So I had a waking dream first 1984.
I had two beehives.
I planted a mushroom in my garden called
the garden giant and one time this
summer I came out to water my mushrooms
and it was covered with bees and the
bees moved the wood chips aside and I
could see these white mycelium and they
were sipping on the little droplets of
oozing from the mycelium.
I got real excited and I kept a journal
and for fortY days from dawn to dusk,
there was a continuous convoy of bees to
my mushroom bed.
Does that edible edible mushrooms?
Um,
and I made note of it.
I published it.
and then harris smith magazine,
1988.
I put it in one of my books in 1994.
And then I forgot about it.
So I got involved with us biosil
biodefense program directly after nine
slash 11.
You can google my name,
stamets and smallpox.
There's a vetted press release from the
us government.
We,
we the,
the,
did 2,200
plus analyses of our mushroom extracts
and we found extracts that were highly
active against flu viruses against
including bird flu against herpes and
against pox viruses,
including smallpox.
So I have a patent that issued on,
this is a great secondary story because
I had black hawk helicopters coming over
my laboratory,
all this other stuff.
So it's a true conspiracy story.
So I had published this research on the
antiviral properties of mushrooms,
the mycelium,
and then I heard about the bees,
you know,
I'd raised bees and then a friend of
mine,
louie schwartzberg,
we're doing a movie called fantastic
fungi making for 10 years.
And louie came to me and said,
paul,
I have eight patents on fungi that can
control termites,
ants,
mosquitoes,
you can google right now.
Stamets can take down monsanto.
There's probably a thousand websites
because my patents are disruptive
patents,
so I can very much control termites.
Ants from consuming your house for about
twenty cents.
And I met with all the big companies
but,
but anyhow,
so louie knew about my research on that.
I've spoken on this before and he said,
paul,
the mites are killing the bees,
can't you do something to help the
mites?
And so now that's two stories.
We have this bio shield biodefense story
and my antiviral stuff.
We have me growing the mushrooms in the
garden and a hike in the old growth
forest a lot and I'm hiking the old
growth for us.
And the way I orienteer it'S one of the
few skill sets I have.
I like just getting off trail and I'm
the south fork of the hoh river and I'm
deep in the old growth forest.
I come around a corner and I see a bear
strike.
The bear came up,
bam,
scratched this tree,
huge paw strike in the tree.
And I told my wife,
I said,
you know,
the Washington state,
the school system is dependent upon
funding from selling timber to the
lumber,
lumber companies.
So the school system dependent upon
timber harvest,
off of public lands.
So in humans,
great wisdom.
They decided that the bears were
jeopardizing the educational funds in
Washington state,
so they hired hunters to kill all the
bears.
So my neighbor killed 400 bears.
That's why we have a salmon run right
now on [inaudible] inlet,
and then chemistry point Washington,
there's no bears around because they saw
the bears,
the threat to the economic stability,
this whole system and why the bears when
they scratch the trees,
it become an entry room for a poly pore
mushrooms.
So I told my wife,
if this is true,
let's come back in two years and see if
this [inaudible] mushroom is growing
there.
These are woodcock similar to the one my
hat is made from.
So we came back two years later and sure
enough this wood conk was growing out of
the tree.
The tree had died,
so they kind of got it right.
So when bears scratch trees,
resin comes out and bees are attracted
to the propolis,
to make propolis from the residence to
pastor hives from cracks,
to prevent invaders coming into a
beehive.
These orals seemingly disparate stories.
And this is why this waking dream put it
all together.
So I have my garden giant in bed with
the bees are coming to the [inaudible]
biodefense program where I found these
extracts are highly active against
viruses,
bear scratched trees,
introduce poly pore mushrooms,
and then with my friend louie
schwartzberg is saying,
you know,
how can you help the bees so and now I
highly recommend this to everybody.
Listening is these lucid dream state at
that state when you're fully asleep and
you just go into the ether of
wakefulness,
stay there,
reside there.
We have random access memory before you
get your neurological pathways all set
up by habit of what you're going to do.
Just exist in that space.
And then I had synopsis activate a new
neurological pathway.
I had an epiphany.
I think I know how to save the bees.
Fast forward now I have multiple patents
issuing all over the world.
We've done research for Washington state
university.
We've gathered two point $5,
million dollars.
You can go to wsu,
www dot b's dot w s u.edu.
So the wasn't the university.edu
for education.
And you'll see the resource that we
have.
There we are.
Now I have found that the extracts of
amadou,
the one my hat is made from doubles the
lifespans of bees and reduces the
deformed wing virus by more than a
thousand fold in 10 days.
I hit joe,
the [inaudible] home run.
I'm not an entomologist.
I have two beehives.
I'm not a big beekeeper,
but I put these thoughts together that
if these mushroom extracts,
reduced viruses that harm humans,
pigs and birds,
what would they do with bees?
Now?
We all grew up with winnie the pooh,
so my us patent issued this past year
and now it's issued in Australia,
United States issuing in europe,
eurasia and Canada.
I plan to open source it for the rest of
the world,
but I was waiting on pins and needles
because certainly it would be something
called prior art.
Patents are issued for and based on
several criteria.
One,
no prior art,
no one's ever mentioned it.
Secondly,
contrary to conventional wisdom,
so if you invented the bicycle,
the wheel,
then you came up with a tricycle.
That's not patentable.
That's pretty obvious because it's
logical.
So you want something as.
No,
no evidence in the literature,
public or private or scientific or
popular.
You want it to contrary to conventional,
conventional wisdom,
which means that you want experts to
teach away from your invention.
So every time someone out there and
tells me that,
that tells,
I hear that paul stamets is full of
crap.
Nothing he says is true.
I have one great response.
I say,
thank you.
You're helping my patentability because
the more experts that teach away from my
invention,
the more unconventional my invention is.
Hence the more patentable it is.
The third criteria is usefulness.
Benjamin franklin could not have
invented the iphone.
There's no usefulness and no self cell
towers.
So there's three criteria for 17 years.
It becomes open source.
So the idea is to incentivize inventors.
That's why you have the iphone,
the droid,
all your computers.
You know,
I had one person call me up in a cell
phone and said,
how dare you patent this?
I go,
how dare you speak to me on a cell phone
that was enabled by a patent so you
could tell me that I shouldn't be
patenting things.
I'm just like,
the contradictions are pretty obvious,
so the patents and now have issued and
there was no prior art,
even though we all grew up with winnie
the pooh,
we knew that bears went into rotted
trees to find honey and beehives.
No one apparently until me made the
connection that bees are attracted to
the mycelium in rotted logs because of
immunological benefit.
Now,
let's go back in time because this is a
very big picture concept here.
Twelve thousand years ago,
we invented agriculture.
What did we do?
We started to deforest.
When we started cutting down the trees,
we began to dismantle the immunological
mycelial nets of nature.
Mycelium needs wood to decompose.
You take away the wood.
There's mycelium doesn't have a habitat
because the mycelium is producing these
antiviral compounds,
rotting the wood,
the bees were attracted,
and because of deforestation,
now we're stressing the bees.
So there's not only the lack of habitat
deforestation,
there's now neonicotinoids behr and
syngenta syngenta that produces neonics
as or known a toxic insecticide,
um,
sponsored research in europe because
they didn't believe that new indicative
noise harm the bees.
There'll be research,
the researchers then finally published
when they got the results that was
contrary to the interests of syngenta
and bear that in fact neonicotinoids
harm.
The second and third generation is now
neonicotinoids are now banned in europe.
They are not banned in the United
States,
so you have drift of these new
indicative to whites on there,
Jason Fields,
so you have loss of wood deforestation,
you have neonicotinoids,
you have gli phosphates,
whether they're associated with gmos
because they interfere with the
microbiome of the bees and their gut
flora,
so they can't detoxify.
It's called the cytochrome p 4:50
pathway that we all have it breaking
down toxins.
So there's a confluence of multiple
stressors,
but the nail in the coffin by far is the
deformed wing virus and we have found
now the extracts of this one drop per
thousand drops.
One milliliter in a leader can reduce
the viruses in bees by more than a
thousand fold and double the lifespan.
So it's a frigging homerun because it
protects food biosecurity around the
world at a time that food ecosystems are
collapsing.
But think of the bigger picture here.
For millions of years,
we were forest people.
We began deforestation.
When we got into agriculture,
we began to dismantle the immunological
networks of nature,
the mycelium,
this resident,
the fact that these same mushrooms that
reduce viruses in bees,
pigs,
birds,
people speaks to me of a bigger concept
that the mycelium is part of the
immunity of the and as we lose the
debris fields that the mycelium is
dependent upon,
we began to dismantle the immunological
health of our environment and zoonotic
diseases,
diseases coming from factory farms,
whether they're from pigs or chicken
farms.
And we have one extraordinary experiment
and this speaks to the black hawk
helicopter story is that I was working
with biosil biodefense program directly
after nine slash 11.
They contacted me because I wrote an
article that was a one page analysis of
all the research on the antiviral
properties of mushrooms in scientific
literature.
I wrote this article published in a peer
reviewed journal.
Bioterrorism became the front and center
of concern of the us defense department.
A group of radiologists saw my article
and they got funded by dick cheney and
George Bush and I have,
you know,
I want to say thank you ironically to
those two because they funded the bio
shield is called project biodefense and
they funded it with several billion
dollars and they contacted me because I
knew I had this large library of about
700 strains of mushrooms in our culture
library.
We have a company of 78 great employees
and we had this large library,
so they said,
we want to test your library based on
this article that you've written,
showing there are antiviral properties
in some mushrooms.
You have a lot of them.
Let's test your library to see if we
have antiviral properties.
So great.
So I started making extracts of
mushrooms,
the fruit bodies,
the mycelium,
the little filamentous fuzzy stuff that
gives rise to mushrooms and I sent off a
hundred extracts at a time all coded
with alphanumeric codes.
So they didn't.
The government didn't know how sending
them.
So I get the first reports come back and
I'm flipping through them.
No activity,
no activity against pox viruses,
because by far the concern was smallpox
the biggest.
We have no immunological defense against
it.
Um,
after 1974 they stopped immunizing.
Do you have a smallpox vaccinaTion on
your arm is probably one of the last
ones that were getting it.
So I'm going through a night,
come to sample 78 and it said high
activity.
Whoa.
You know,
sample 81 high activity.
Whoa.
I got really excited.
I looked at my notebook,
what the codes were,
and it was from this mushroom called
[inaudible] that grows exclusively in
the old growth forests of the pacific
northwest.
This is the longest living mushroom in
north America.
It's a perennial poly poor.
It looks like a giant beehive by
coincidence up on a tree so you can get
a picture of jana.
And so a garrick on a g,
a r I,
k o,
n and a.
So I got real excited and I Was given a
contact person because he had one point
of contact with us,
the defense department,
a physician,
and I called him up saying,
these researchers,
these research results are wonderful.
He goes,
what research results?
I go,
federal express just delivered me this
whole dossier and the first hundred
samples,
wow,
look at that.
And,
and he goes,
you're not supposed to get those.
I am.
I said,
well,
I'll photocopy and send them to you.
So he didn't think that was too funny,
but that's the us government sometimes
is not very well organized.
The left hand doesn't talk to the right
hand.
So we got these research results.
It's crazy.
That looks like a stick up a dude's.
But this one is particularly unusual
because it was attached to an upper
branch.
It fell through the air,
hit the other branch and teeter tottered
and then it regrew it's mycelium and it
connected back into the mother.
Mycelium inside the tree.
And then it grew two legs.
So this is like,
this was first described by the ice
core.
It says 65 is ed as [inaudible] ad
longum vitam the elixir of long life.
So this has been used in greek
pharmacopoeia for,
for,
for thousands of years.
So please get back to your store.
Sorry for the interruption.
It's one aisle.
I'm up in Canada.
And one of my managers calls me up,
says paul,
there's a helicopter who are the
laboratories?
I go,
no big deal.
And helicopters come and go because no,
it's really close.
And I said,
how close?
He goes,
listen to go,
whoa,
that's really close.
I go,
what are the numbers in the back of the
helicopter?
And he goes,
there are no numbers as a black hawk
helicopter.
And I went,
oh my gosh now just because it was very
new in the program with.
Because when you have an antidote to a
weapon than it can be weaponized by
terrorists.
So they didn't know who.
Not everybody in the government knew who
I was.
Even though I was working with project
biodefense,
I was still sort of an unknown entity
and I filed a patent application on
this.
And so I told my manager,
okay,
shut down the business.
Give everybody cultures of this
mushroom,
which was [inaudible].
I don't want to know who has them shut
down the business.
Everyone spread.
So we decentralized ourselves at target.
But hold on,
let me stop you right there.
So you're in Canada,
Canada,
and the United States.
In Washington state and the helicopters
are flying over your lab,
what happens then?
Well,
they were trying.
They were spooking us do it on purpose.
They were doing the purpose.
They were hovering to let you know
they're there.
I don't know what they were doing.
I mean there are treetop level right
over the frigging laboratory.
So I had everyone go in their car.
They asked everyone to go in their car,
shut down the business immediately and
decentralize us as a target.
So later on when I came back,
I called the people in the defense
department saying,
what the hell's going on here?
And they go,
oh geez,
you know,
sometimes the left hand doesn't talk to
her.
Right?
Or sorry.
So eventually.
So how did they find out that you just
from your patent filing with the patent?
I filed the patent and it disappeared.
Most patent applications when you file
them show up in the us patent homepage,
within a year or two I filed this patent
and four or five years later it still
had not been published.
So I get a hold of my patent attorney
who gets ahold of the patent office and
the us department of defense considered
it to be an act national security,
so they quarantined my patent,
took it out of the patent office,
and they so it could not be seen by
potential terrorists because then it
could have an antidote to smallpox.
So I had to do an inner government,
a governmental agency,
trace to recall the patent from dod,
that meetings they let out to be
released because it was a natural
product.
And so the patent then was put back into
the patent application queue and it was
approved in 2013.
I filed it in 2004.
So we have now done work at the
university of Mississippi school of
pharmacy.
We've isolated two novel anti smallpox
molecules.
We also have done work at the
tuberculosis research institute with Dr.
Scott France plow and university of
Illinois chicago.
We've identified a new anti-tuberculosis
molecule,
a garicoitz and [inaudible] time in
greek culture was used for treating
consumption later thought to be known as
tuberculosis.
We have found that extracts of this
mushroom are dually active against
bacteria and viruses.
Most people who die from viral pneumonia
actually die from bacterial pneumonia.
They get a viral infection.
Their immune system over amps and
response.
You get flood,
lungs get flooded with liquid bacteria
setup and bacterial pneumonia usually
kills people who actually get a flu
virus.
They die from bacterial pneumonia,
so to find a natural product that's
dually active against viruses and
bacteria is medically significant.
So there's a good argument for natural
products because you have a consortium
of protective agents that are living in
this soup of this extract that can help
help protect you.
So this has now led onto our discovering
molecules active against hpv.
The human papilloma virus.
Seventy percent or more of women have
hpv controversial vaccine.
Apparently it's very dangerous.
Well,
I'm not anti vaccination,
but I'm not either,
but I'm curious why they don't recommend
the vaccine after the age of 24.
I can't wrap my mind around.
I think they're just trying to prevent
infection from sexually active kids
while you're sexually active after the
age of 24.
So why?
When they're sexually active before
then,
but if you were didn't have the
infection before 24 and you're still
active at the age of 24,
why wouldn't they recommend the
vaccination after the age of 24?
Maybe there's a good medical recommended
post 24 hours that we were just 24 also
post 24.
They don't recommend it because they
think maybe you already have it.
I don't know the answer to that.
That's bizarre.
I've never been able to get someone to
explain to me why is it the case?
Mushrooms can suppress the expression of
this is that we were saying the
ingredients within the mushrooms.
We have found five molecules
authenticated by nih virology as being
potently active against hpv.
Which mushrooms,
uh,
all the poly pores that I have been
talking about,
a ratio air-con,
amadu are likely,
we don't,
I can't say de facto,
all of them to have varying amounts of
these constituents.
So these mushroom extracts are huge
consortium of antiviral and
antibacterial compounds.
Now,
as I mentioned,
this maybe 5 million species of fungi is
about 150,000
species of mushrooms we've identified
around 14,000,
so think of from a just from
experientials evidence over thousands of
years of human experimentation.
It'd be like you went into a library and
there's 14,000
books in your library,
14,000
species,
and our ancestors started selecting each
of these species and testing them.
We've narrowed the field down to about
200 species of which 50 species are
superstars that have no adverse effects
to human ingestion that had been used
for a very long period of time and
within that set of 50 species we're
finding these mushrooms which have
tremendous potential health benefit.
So this is why I'm so excited in the
field of mycology is we have
translational science.
We have applied mycology,
and I think based on what we've
discovered,
we can make the argument that we should
save the old growth forest as a matter
of national defense.
Our fungal genomes are essential for our
future and present survival.
The more we eliminate these landscapes
of biodiversity,
the more really losing potential agents
that can fight disease,
and so this is something that I think we
can build a bridge between conservatives
and liberals because osama bin ladin and
have access to an old growth forest.
We did and we do,
and I think this is really just
indicative of many other things that we
can discover if we pay attention to the
vast genomic resources we have in the
biodiversity of the ecosystems that are,
that are still intact.
Now.
Do you recommend for personal
consumpTion any particular mushrooms,
any particular supplements?
I in terms of recommend recommendations
for gourmet mushrooms,
I can make those.
In terms of recommendations for
medicinal mushrooms,
I cannot make recommendations.
I'm legally tied by the fda.
I cannot make a recommendation.
Can you recommend a website that perhaps
would recommend?
Well,
I do recommend eating gourmet mushrooms
for,
for just for a sheet talky,
lion's mane,
my talky and reishi and chaga,
and these all have medical benefits as
well.
These all,
I don't know the difference between a
gourmet and a medicinal medicinal
mushrooms.
Mushrooms,
mushrooms are medicinal.
Mushrooms are medicinal.
Mushrooms are very,
very medicinal.
The big,
the big stars right now by far are
reishi,
chaga,
and lion's mane.
What about portabella?
They taste too good.
They can't be that good for you.
Poor bellows,
have a problem.
I knew all mush.
All mushrooms should be cooked and
portobellos in particular should be
cooked at high temperatures.
Why?
There is a unfortunate google compound
called at garret.
Uh,
garret teens are hydrazine's that are
heat unstable.
So the good news is you should cook
them.
And if you cook them well,
then those mushrooms are not a problem.
If you don't cook them well,
then these hydrazine's are potentially
problematic.
Now,
nature's a numbers game.
So there are beneficial compounds that
in some balance may outweigh the
negative effects of the hydrazine's,
the garrett teens in these mushrooms.
But that jury is still out.
So what are the negative benefits or the
negative affects of this?
This is an explosive area of
conversation and puts my life in danger.
So I reserve the right not to answer a
question.
Whoa.
I didn't expect that.
It puts your life in danger.
Talking about portabella mushrooms.
He's looking at me silently.
I will respectfully move on.
Thank you.
So anybody who's interested,
just google that and get back to me
next.
I'm going to have a guy who was the same
height as paul and he's going to have a
mask on and we're going to have some
sort of electric box that distorts his
voice.
No,
but the good news there is lots of
mushrooms that have tremendous benefit
and compounds inside of portabella
mushrooms that are very beneficial and
in fact there is a positive study with
some breast cancer patients.
Breast cancer study showing that that
button mushrooms can confer benefits.
So there that you know,
we.
We were funded by nih with a two point
$2,000,000
for a breast cancer clinical study on
Turkey tail mushrooms and Turkey tail
mushrooms are fantastic as adjuncts to
conventional therapy.
The clinical study that was conducted
funded by nih and the university of
Minnesota medical school and medical
college showed a dose response curve
specifically in supporting the immune
system by taking Turkey tail mushrooms
and the more you talk,
the more benefit there was.
I have a ted med talk that's very
popular in front of 800 physicians where
my mother,
who is challenged with advanced stage
four breast cancer,
who is now 90,
almost 93 years of age.
She had advanced stage four breast
cancer when she was 84 years of age,
given less than a few months to live,
and she had metastasized tumors all over
her body.
Her breast was erupting with a very,
very bad carcinoma and she is alive well
and fully recovered today.
She did.
She had chemotherapy using herceptin and
little short time taxol.
She had a very bad reaction to taxol,
but there's a scientific articles now
been published saying that showing that
Turkey tail mushroom constituents help
conventional therapies like
chemotherapy,
the herceptin and making herceptin work
better.
So there's a nice blending of
integrative medicine with using natural
products with conventional medicine.
I will never be say that you should not
consult a physician.
I will never say that you should not use
conventional medicine.
You should is the state of the art of
science is right there,
but the state of the arts and sciences
that we can upregulate immunity with
these mushrooms and that's your front
line of defense and then the other
conventional therapies that are being
practiced now combine very,
very nicely according to many physicians
and reports showing that the combination
of Turkey tail mushrooms in combination
with conventional therapy can have a
significant difference in improving your
immunological defense.
No,
I absolutely agree with you that
conventional treatments are state of the
art and this is state of the art
science.
When you're talking about dealing with
cancer,
you should deal with oncologists that
are at the cutting edge,
but they're not state of the art when it
comes to the preventing of these things
and that that's a giant issue that a lot
of people have when it comes to
nutrition,
lifestyle,
mitigating stress,
all the various factors that contribute
to a bunch of different health ailments.
Do you think that mushrooms could also
play a factor in that as well?
Absolutely.
There's a great epidemiological study
that came out of Japan and dr.
Valois was a epidemiologist that worked
for the national cancer center in tokyo
and they noticed and surveying people in
Japan in the 19 sixties,
early 19 seventies,
there was a dearth,
a drop in the overall cancer rate and
this one population in nagano prefecture
in Japan,
so he was sent there by the national
cancer center of tokyo,
by the government to say what are these
people doing?
And this one cluster of villages where
they have statistically significant less
cancer rates.
We're talking about 30 percent less than
the national average.
And after exhaustive study he found that
they were eating enoki mushrooms.
A lot of them,
because the enoki mushrooms are really
thin ones,
like really tall stems.
You can buy them in the store.
Well,
the font,
there was a big farming centers for
enoki mushrooms there and then the
blemished ones as us.
Roberta,
there's no.
We don't sell to the public,
the ones that have little spots on them
or are deformed,
but they are given to the workers and so
their workers and then their families
eat a higher per capita consumption of
enoki mushrooms than the other residents
of Japan.
So they found that specifically the
consumption of enoki mushrooms resulted
in a reduction of cancer across the
board of all cancers.
Statistically significant,
I think over 220,000
people in this epidemiological survey.
I've written about 10 articles for the
huffington post and you can google
stamets,
huffington post and enoki mushrooms and
see all the citations on enoki mushrooms
on lion's mane on [inaudible].
All these mushrooms I'm talking about,
they're all peer reviewed past
physicians.
They're all very short articles,
but they summarize a lot of the research
that I'm talking about.
That's amazing.
Um,
what,
what do you know about the quarter eps
mushroom?
I know a fair amount about cortisol.
Yeah.
I'm fascinated for two reasons.
One,
because of a supplement that I take that
my company makes called true tech sport,
sorry for the name.
My apologies in advance,
buT it's based on athletic performance,
but the shroom tech is based on the
quarter steps and be 12 and a bunch of
different adaptogens.
And the idea being that when you take
that it benefits athletic performance,
benefits,
endurance and oxygen utilization.
And apparently they discoVered this from
what?
It's a weird one because they grow it
on,
on a caterpillar,
d,
do you know about all that?
Yeah.
Cordyceps is now has been split into
several different gentlemen.
Yeah,
bring up.
The other one is the one that explodes
on ants.
Yeah,
there's a.
There's a quarter steps.
Sinensis now known as [inaudible]
sinensis.
cordyceps has about 500 species in it.
It's been a very complicated taxonomy
because when researchers would go in the
himalayas and they find these
caterpillars for the quarter system
mushrooms coming out of it,
very good scientists,
and they did this.
What I would do,
they would take it in a laboratory.
They would break it open and take a
piece of tissue from the inside.
They.
It's called cloning.
So you just capture their genetic
material.
You grow out the culture.
Very confusing because there's five
different fungi.
They're called anna morphs.
Cordyceps is a dimorphic fungus.
what that means as two forms,
it's got a mold state and it's got a
mushroom state.
The mushroom state comes up like a
little club,
looked like your finger would go,
orange,
little finger coming up out of the
ground so you can find that jamie and
the.
Yeah,
so is this a expired caterpillar?
I can't actually see the species there,
but it looked like they're beetles,
so there's a number of core set of
species.
So when there was a lot of scientific
dispute on what the true anamorphic,
now it's two sides of the same coin.
You see the quarter and then you clone
it and you get this mold growing and
then people will grow up the mold.
Well now we know there are several
species of molds that are growing inside
the caterpillar,
so the true cost us a quarter step
sinensis is now identified as her tele
condensed sinensis.
That's the true one facility on my cs
and monetarism and all these other ones
are not considered to be the true
organism.
They're chasing the other quarters steps
mold inside of the mushroom.
Whoa.
Well,
I can't keep up with you.
This isn't going to be one that I'm
going to go over many,
many,
many poly culture,
poly call polyculture with several
different entimopathogenic fungi.
These are fungi that kill insects,
so I mean this is very,
very disruptive because all of the fda
and the labeling and how do you label
this or what do you do and who's right
and who's wrong and how do you get the
labeling to conform with the current
taxonomy based on dna research.
The good news is based on the best of my
knowledge,
the several of these companies that are
selling these quarter steps,
they anam wharfs even though they may
not be the true cordyceps sinensis.
Those also confer benefits so you can
argue in a sense about different
species.
The problem with this is there's no less
than a thousand peer reviewed articles
on quarter acep,
sinensis and no one or hardly anyone.
No one knows what species they were
actually growing because if we don't
know which,
which of these animal wars there were
actually growing was this recent
information is all very recent.
All in the past four or five years,
and especially in the past two years,
so it's taxonomy is in flux because the
dna pcr amplification in the region of
dna that they've chosen to amplify there
are idiosyncratic to the species.
Now that story has changed.
Whole genome sequencing is really the
only way to go about this where they
sequence the entire genome and so there
was a lot of elasticity or plasticity in
the expression of dna.
Now going back,
what we've been talking about,
this whole interview,
epa,
genesis,
is the an environmental stimulus has a
selective influence on the genomic
expression of the individual species
yourself and so you up regulate or turn
on genes that are otherwise quote
unquote asleep.
And so what we're seeing now is that
epigenetic influences can cause
different dna expressions and so what
was considered to be conformity of a
species in dna types before like 99
percent.
And that was thought that,
oh,
we're the same species.
Now we know that's highly inaccurate.
So what was accurate a few years ago is
considered to be highly inaccurate
today.
The science is changing very,
very rapidly and the regulatory
environment cannot catch up,
so it doesn't really matter except for
the following,
and this is I do make a recommendation
here,
make sure your mushrooms or whatever
products you're consuming are certified
organic and please don't buy them from
China.
Anyone who's been to China,
I've been to China several times.
The amount of massive air pollution
there is horrific and the chain of
custody as we call it,
where are these people are getting their
mushrooms because they had mixed
oftentimes distributors,
mixed suppliers and as a form of quote
unquote russian roulette.
We've done analyses on chinese sourced
mushrooms and they've had up to 2100
parts per million of lead where two or
three capsules is toxic.
So why would you take a medicinal
mushroom that's contaminated with heavy
metals and pesticides?
You're trying to improve your immune
system at the same time.
You're sabotaging your immune system,
so getting mushrooms from clean
environments is critically important.
Unfortunately,
because the usda organic program they
can borrow from the organic programs of
China is still say they're certified
organic,
so you really need to buy us grown
certified organic mushrooms that have a
clear chain of custody and hopefully one
that is from a reputable supplier or
scientist and not somebody who's just
trying to make money.
There's a lot of opportunistic companies
right now who are just trying to exploit
and ride the bandwagon of the popularity
of medicinal mushrooms without really
having done their homework or without
fully informing the public that their
mushrooms are actually coming from China
when they are not.
What is the strain of cordyceps mushroom
that erupts,
that infects ants,
kills them,
sprouts out of them,
and then explodes and infects the ants
near them and other ants will drag that
ant knowing that it's infected deep,
deep away into the forest,
away from the column just quarter.
Lord dei up on the screen there,
pulled up.
We of course step laurie dei,
you lateralis is another one of these
zombie movies he'd been saying have been
based on cordyceps and next.
I was actUally,
I was a character in hannibal lecter.
You were?
Yeah,
in the series.
I think it's number five and and l I
think elvin stamets.
Was this anesthesiologist gave your last
name?
Yeah,
use my last name and they just call you
paul.
Well they do on star trek.
I'm a character instructor.
They actually call me paul stamets on
star trek,
but hannibal lecter that series.
I let people write me,
said,
oh my gosh,
you're this evil doctor who overdoses
his patients with drugs and then puts
them in the backyard and then inoculates
with mushrooms just like cordyceps
mushrooms growing in the backyard.
And some of the star trek people called
me up in august of 2016.
I'm talking to them.
They cbs set it up.
They have to talk to you.
They saw my ted talk and,
and they said,
paul,
we're the writers of the star trek
discovery series.
We're kind of stuck,
you know,
we want to talk to you.
We saw your ted talk really interested.
And I go,
wait a second,
are you the one who put me in hannibal
lecter?
It goes,
yeah.
And I go,
well,
let's get it right this time,
you know.
so I said,
okay.
I said,
foolishly,
or maybe to my benefit,
I said,
turn on your tape recorder,
give me the general idea,
let me run with it.
And they said,
okay,
go for it.
There's six of them I guess in the
conference call.
foolishly,
I said,
I'm a star trek fan,
which is not foolish,
but I want no money for these ideas.
I give you all my intellectual property.
I want science fiction to predict
science.
Fact,
the great thing about star trek is the
flip phone and the ipad came out and
start truck and then it became reality.
I said,
so you have a unique opportunity here of
forming our future.
Let's collaborate to create a future
that's better for our future
generations,
by inspiring students and young people
to get excited about the science so they
can help populate the universities to
create the inventions that can help save
this planet.
That's in jeopardy.
And so I ran with the star trek theme
and we just saw the last episode last
night and astrobiologist paul stamets is
using the mycelium spore drive.
It is become,
I couldn't believe it.
We're watching this thing and star trek,
the main theme of star trek is based on
mycelium and the concepts that I gave
them.
They've elaborated this six ways to
sunday,
so they've really taken it misses as
some sort of a propulsion system.
It's a system.
Because in my ted talk,
and I've been talking about this a long
time about networks,
we have the mycelial network,
we have the computer internet,
we have the neurological network in our
brains.
And the ordination of dark matter
conforms to string theory.
So these are three archetypes,
the same archetype,
the same dimensional structures stacked
on top of each other and nature builds
upon its prior successes.
So networks reward themselves by
surviving.
And it was from catastrophic.
So I said I'm still bound by
confidentiality.
And there's an incredibly strict
confidentiality agreement.
I can only state which has been publicly
displayed,
but the mycelium spore allows through
the internet of nature,
you might say,
to be able to go into hyperspace
immediately by tapping into the mycelial
archetype.
And so astro mycologist stamets now is
plugging himself into the mycelial
network of the universe and they can
jump rather than using their standard
hyper drives,
which you see them streaming across for
hours from one part of the university,
the other,
they can show up immediately and then
then disappear.
Is this something that you think could
actually be real?
One day?
I am.
Okay.
You're gonna.
We're pushing the envelope,
pushing the envelope on this one,
but if you look at the multiverse and
I've had a.
I've had a one or two in particular
multiverse experiences where time and
reality has changed in a way that I
cannot explain it.
So what do you mean it's so incredibly
profound that I still cannot wrap my
mind around it.
And um,
these are psilocybin experiences
psilocybin experienced.
So I think the psilocybin experience
might be a one will portal.
And now I'm going to sound like terence
mckenna vendoring in the to the
multiverse.
The idea that time can be bent,
that there are multiple universes
occurring simultaneously in different
realities.
And I've had one experience in
particular that is just unfathomable to
me.
I don't know how to explain it is okay.
I'll give it a shot.
You've already blown my mind this 50
times today.
This is a very deeply personal
experience to me,
but I was um,
I was going to the evergreen state
college.
I had the drug enforcement
administration license.
My brother john went to yale university.
He got a graduate scholarship in
neurophysiology at the university of
Washington.
He came out to Washington state and
seattle.
I was living in olympia,
Washington.
I had a cabin up in the mountains near
darrington,
Washington of the summertime for three
years.
I set chokers.
I was a logger.
I really believe in the school of hard
knocks and the blending of academia with
blue collar,
hard work.
I love chopping wood.
I love running a chainsaw.
I love hard labor.
I think it gives my mind some respite to
be able to think.
So I'm in this highly academic
environment.
My brother john,
he died unfortunately two years ago,
soon.
See he got me involved in mushrooms,
so I'm going to segue and set the stage
here,
but I needed another two minutes to set
the stage here.
So I'm growing up in a small town in
Ohio called columbiana.
My brother john goes to is going to
yale.
He comes back one day and it gives me a
book that he usually for his class,
but he's on break and he said,
I am really fascinated and john went to
Mexico.
Colombia,
came back with great stories of eating
psilocybin mushrooms and he's my older
brother.
I just idolized him and his book called
older states of consciousness.
And so I said,
john,
can I borrow your book?
He said,
sure.
And he said,
but paul and you get back from my break
is over and going back to college and
this is part of our textbook.
So I borrowed his book,
altered states of consciousness.
I'm just fascinated reading it about all
these different ways of expanding your
consciousness.
I'm 14 years of age and so my best
friend Ryan Snyder says,
paul,
can I borrow your book?
We're hanging together all the time,
and I go,
yeah,
but my idea back,
so he borrows my book and he doesn't
return it a day.
SeverAl days,
pass a week,
pass,
two weeks pass.
My brother's coming back on break.
I said I needed that book ball back.
Paul and I go to ryan.
I go,
ryan,
I need my book.
I need my book,
and ryan kept on avoiding the answering
the subject and to finally give me my
book,
and ryan goes,
I can't give it to you,
paul.
I said,
why is my dad burned it?
I see your dad burned my brother's book.
I go,
wtf?
I didn't use this phrase back then.
I said,
oh my god,
and I have a shout out to ryan snyder's
father because of that event.
It stimulated my interest in altered
states of consciousness even more so
that john goes to yale and it goes to
the university of Washington.
I have this dea permit.
I'm at the evergreen state college.
John calls me up and he says,
paul,
I think I found some psilocybin
mushrooms.
John said,
you're really smart.
You've been collecting sloppy cubensis
in Colombia and Mexico,
but this is much more complicated up
here.
I said,
let me ask you a few questions.
okay,
john,
can you take a spore print?
He goes,
yes,
I go,
spores purple,
brown,
and he goes,
yes,
they are purple brown.
I go,
good.
John separable,
gelatinous pellicle,
and he goes,
what's that?
And I go,
well,
break the cap.
These are growing on wood chips.
Break the cap and separate the cap very
slowly.
Do you see a little skin that's
translucent?
And he breaks it and goes,
yeah,
I see that skin.
The john the growing in wood chips,
and he goes,
yes.
I go,
are they turning bluish?
He goes,
yes,
they're staining really bright blue go,
wow.
I said,
john,
how many did you find?
He goes,
you would not believe it is a huge
amount.
I said,
wait.
paul,
they're in a very sensitive place.
You better come up here right away.
So I jumped in my car and I drove up
from olympia to seattle about 60,
70 miles.
I get to his house and john's there and
I go,
well,
where are we going to say,
well we need some grocery bags and let's
get on our bikes and let's go down
there.
I go,
why all the secrecy and the promise is,
well you'll see.
And it was the end of boat street and
right at the university of Washington,
right off of university avenue.
There's boat street and we get there and
right across the street as a police
substation.
So we're there and it was an eruption of
this mushroom that had to be 10,000,
30,000
mushrooms,
I don't know,
is about 50 feet by 30 feet with all
been cultured wood chips.
There was an eruption that picked up
trash and debris that picked up six
inches,
was solid mushrooms there.
Mushrooms everywhere.
To this day,
never seen so many mushrooms in one
concentrated area.
So we waited until the police cars went
away and were kind of idling there.
And then the police cars will go away
and from the substation.
And we'd start picking mushrooms,
picking mushrooms,
and we fill up a grocery bag or two and
then the other students are walking by,
what are you doing?
Oh,
nothing.
You know?
And then we eventually got plenty for
everybody.
So it was like pretty good.
Everyone's all hanging out as a little
group like at the bus stop,
right?
We're not really waiting for the bus.
Right.
We're waiting for the police cars to go
away.
And then we picked all these mushrooms
and so we got about eight or 10 grocery
bags full of these mushrooms help as it
turned out to be a new species of called
philosophy students.
See I'm named after him.
No species,
new species,
as in hadn't been discovered with had
never been described in the scientific
literature and before.
So you picked a mushroom that no one
knew existed but hadn't been.
Hadn't been described scientifically.
We had known about it for about three
years,
but this is a largest eruption.
And from that collection became part of
the type collection that anchored the
species taxonomically.
So I think some of the specimens still
exist in her barrier around the world
because it's the reference standard.
So we go back to the house and it's like
we gotta dry them,
so we lay out newspapers and the whole,
the whole newspapers were just covered
with mushrooms.
And,
and so that night we just above four
guys from yale,
all neurophysiology,
all scientists on scientist track them,
eat them.
And so,
I mean,
this is not very potent there.
One 10th the potency of cubensis.
So we made smoothies and uh,
oh my gosh,
talk about the gag reflex.
So we had to make these foods,
we have 50 of them in order to have a
dose equivalent equivalent to westlaw
speak.
Vince's would be.
So I knew that.
So we made these incredibly distasteful
Milkshakes and we chugged them,
we drank them.
And then amazing experience.
I bonded with my brother,
it was beautiful.
And then you're peaking at the
experience.
You look around and there's like tens of
thousands is modular.
Like,
oh my gosh,
all for science.
Um,
and so I go To bed and I'm laying in bed
in full blown experience.
And can barely sleep because all the
colors are keeping me awake and my mind
is racing and then I have a lucid dream
and I'm dreaming and I wake up and I go
downstairs,
I go,
I had this crazy dream.
What's your dream?
And I said,
I saw thousands of cattle dead baking in
the sun.
I said,
I think there's going to be a nuclear
war,
but what could kill all these cattle,
you know,
at the time,
the reagan administration and all that,
the tension was really high between the
soviet union and United States.
And they said,
and they were joking with me saying,
oh,
well,
okay,
you know,
when it's gonna to happen,
I go,
I know I was in olympia and I needed to
rush up to darrington to stay in my
cabin because my books are up there.
My manuscript was up there.
I need to save,
save my research.
So they laughed and they laughed.
They said,
well,
when's the world going to end?
Paul?
And I go,
well,
there's not this weekend.
That was like in two days,
it's next weekend.
So they wrote on the calendar,
December 1st,
I put it in my book,
I think it's 1975,
the end of the world that wrote,
paul predicts the end of the world.
So we forgot about it.
Massive rains the next week,
huge amounts of snowfall.
And then on wednesday,
thursday,
temperature inversion,
and it flipped to 75 to 85 degrees.
All the snow started to melt.
All the rivers were flooding and my
little cabin was right next to this
river that would swell from date and
have a morning tonight.
It go up six feet just from the snow
melt.
And because we're very close to this
volcano and the glaciers as,
oh my gosh,
I'm gonna lose my manuscript.
All my research.
I need to get up there,
I need to go up there.
And so I'm watching the news on news and
the roads are being closed.
So I had to go through rockport,
Washington,
the back way in order to get back to my
cabin.
I get to my cabin and the bank had
eroded about 10 feet.
I was only about 10,
12 feet away from the,
from the river.
Now my cabin was on the verge of falling
into it,
but I thought my manuscript,
I got all my books and I rescued all the
material,
had medical and get out of there because
the roads that have been closed and so I
had to wait,
wait two days,
two days and the roads then opened up
and I drove out out of the valley and to
snohomish valley and I went around the
bend and there the son that was a
brilliant sunny day,
a warm day and there floating in the
fields were hundreds and hundreds of
dead cattle.
How do you explain that?
I entered,
I think into the multiverse.
Oh,
now as a scientist,
you realize when you say something like
that,
you open yourself up to ridicule.
Do you feel hesitant to communicate
these ideas?
to a degree,
yes,
but you know,
I'm 62 years of age and you know,
at one point I just don't care.
I just don't care.
You know,
this is true.
This happened to me and I can push the
envelope on these ideas because the
credibility of My research as well
established.
I can save the bees.
Do you care whether I have taken
silicide mushrooms?
If I can save your farm,
your family,
your country or the world?
Billions of dollars and protect
biosecurity.
I care more.
That's right.
So I'm telling you things.
I'm not making these up.
I just.
But just because you can't explain it
does not mean it's not true and I think
that we need to accept the fact that the
reality is not limited to the perception
that we have traditionally used.
That's a beautiful way to describe it.
Let's end with that.
That's perfect.
Thank you brother paul.
Thank you so much.
I'm so glad you came here and thank you
to all the people that recommended you
and turned me onto your work.
And can we do this again?
I'd love to please.
All right.
And if people want to research more of
your stuff,
fungi.com.
And what was the other website and host
defense.com.
Host defense.com.
And there's a ton of other information,
ted talk
and I like youtube.com/paul
stamets site and louie schwartzberg a
shout out.
We have a fantastic fungi.com.
Check it out.
Louis,
now are coming out with a movie that
describes much of this stuff.
Thank you so much.
All right.
Thank you brother.
Woo.
That was awesome.